turn on my microphone that'd be awesome
okay
uh 9:30 we are going to open the public
hearing for House Bill
1021 and we will recognize the prime
sponsor who sponsoring this hin uh
representative
Hines oh geez please have a seat and
join us for the
pledge to the flag of the United States
of America and tobl for it stands one
nation God indivisible liy andice for
all red thank you kind of backwards
thank you uh Madam chair um and I
appreciate all my bills being scheduled
for one day so you guys have to deal
with me all day but uh hopefully by the
end day learn some more about the
criminal justice process um so by way of
background I'm a criminal defense lawyer
pretty much everything I do is DWI
defense and this first bill relates to
body warant cameras body Waring cameras
are great um when I first started
practicing law more than 15 years ago
pretty much no departments had that um
since then I would say that has
increased by over a th% State Police use
them um I think rough I I think more
than half of the Town departments do use
them in some form um so they're great um
they're great for police if someone
makes a false accusation someone can
look at the video see what happens if
someone alleges um excessive force
someone can look at the video see what
happens it's always good for defendants
make sure that police reports and police
testimony aligns with what actually
happened um overall helps public
confidence um the public can see these
videos um and address it and uh just
coming forward a little bit um I think
one of the problems with the president's
statute is what happens to that video um
so my um Bill makes it that the
defendant is entitled to copy share that
video um I suggest there's a public
interest in um body warn camera videos
um so across the country in the last few
years there's been instances of
excessive police force to say a minimum
and a lot of times those things have
been put on camera um they've been
spread on YouTube um and ultimately it
leaves to leads to what I would suggest
suggest is the most Fair outcome of
those cases um if there weren't video in
those cases I would suggest that the uh
outcome might often be different so is
important for not just the defendant um
but public as a society to have access
to these body warn camera videos and
unfortunately um the president statute
limits that um so my bill is addressing
or looking to address that um first some
departments take the position that the
statute as presently written
um doesn't really provide defense
lawyers or the defendant with um access
to that video I think that's a wrong
reading of the statute um but even if
the statute did say hey defendant can't
have this video statute would be
patently unconstitutional um under state
constitution defendants have a right to
all proofs favorable certainly that
includes exculpatory evidence certainly
includes body warant camera video um so
the defendant has the right to those
videos um in certain instances um there
could be privacy issues um where perhaps
the state might want to redact it um um
I can think of cases where um there
might be nudity involved so I it's
reasonable for the state to redact
certain portions where necessary um and
the state can get protective orders to
do that so before they release the video
they can tell the judge hey we want to
limit this part of the video and
hopefully the defense has an opportunity
to be heard because one option is what's
called an in camera review hearing U so
a judge can look at the evidence if they
want to say all right fine don't provide
this or provide this or issue some type
of order so it's clear what should be
released to the defendant um so that's
one part of my bill it just says the
defendant is entitled to this footage um
another part of the bill is that um the
evidence shouldn't be destroyed um in
criminal cases so um I think the present
statute kind of is ambiguous in that
regard uh where it deals with time
frames for Destruction um another part
does say that it um shouldn't really be
destroyed while cases are pending uh one
potential issue is even if a case is
over it's not completely over over so
there can be post-trial relief motions
um so two that come to mind if someone
wants a new trial um one could be for an
effective assistance of council that's
where their original lawyer did
something wrong um and the court will
have to look at all the evidence and
decide whether it rises to that um and
without having that video in a lot of
these cases it's not really possible to
look at that um I could foresee a case
where let's just say the lawyer said nah
the video was a couple hours long I
don't really want to sit through it and
watch that video like well we don't know
what's on the video If you destroyed it
so um I think at a minimum the defendant
should be able to retain that video for
all they want for as long as they want I
think the defendant is entitled to share
that video in the way they want with
certain exceptions again if there's
privacy issues again a protective order
a case-by casee basis can deal with that
um the other part of this bill that um
repeals the part where officers can only
use body warant camera videos while
they're in uniform um I think generally
police probably do want to only use it
while in uniform I gu think of there
might be cases where they might not so
if there's an undercover officer who
worked on a case for a while maybe he's
involved with the executing a search
warrant after the fact perhaps he wants
to put a body warrant camera video on um
perhaps someone's off duty an officer he
has one with him um so I don't know how
common it will be but I don't think we
should be prohibiting the police just
100% saying you can never have officers
use these videos unless they um are in
you know form so this would just allow
them uh the department if they want to
do it in certain cases and the other
important part of this um my bill which
I think is one of the most important
parts is that it stops police from
turning off the videos while they're
speaking with other police I don't know
why that was put in the original statute
but there is a major problem with it um
also um I used to be a member of New
Hampshire Association criminal defense
lers um it's my understanding they sent
an email with some possible amendments
hopefully to the entire committee I did
see it got sent to the chair
um so my part of the bill just repeals
that section altogether because officers
once they turn on that video they should
not turn off that video uh what happens
in DWI cases I've seen it numerous times
um one particular agency tends to do it
more than the others um but they're
doing their investigation like they
should um it's usually after the point
field sobriety tests are done um at that
point in most cases after field soety
tests some officers will offer a
portable breath task but if they don't
do that at that point it's the decision
time for the officer am I going to
arrest this person for DWI or am I going
to let him go and a lot of newer
officers um or even other officers
consult with other officers before they
make that decision so I have cases where
the field Sprite tests are done the
officer goes speaks with another officer
mutes his microphone comes back and
arrests um I only get the cases where
someone arrests I'm sure somewhere out
there there's other cases where the
person doesn't get arrested I only get
the arrest cases
and I after the case I see like why is I
see the video being muted I'm like what
happened to this um I originally didn't
know that the statute presently
prohibits that and I just think that's
absolutely ridiculous uh but whenever I
asked the officer well what happened
during that conversation either they
don't recall or a lot of times it was
related to something other than the
actual case I think it's ridiculous that
an officer in the middle right before
they make an arrest is going to start
speaking about another case um so
unfortunately potentially exculpatory
evidence is destroyed when that video is
muted um if there are privacy concerns
they can redact it after the fact they
should not be eliminating the video in
the first place because we do not know
what happens and I think I know what
happens I think they're talking about
the case they might say well this is a
close case I don't know if I were going
to arrest and one supervising Officer
says just arrest see if he gives a
breath test back at the station um so
without that video we just don't know
what happens um so those are three
things my bill does um it's my
understanding the
um NH HAC CDL has proposed some
Amendment language and i would support
their language um it looks like they're
doing the three same things as I am
trying to do um just in a slightly
different way um so I'm fine with their
language if um committee wants to do
that and I believe someone from their
organization might be here testify to
that um so you can ask them questions
about it but I would support their
language does the three things that I'm
looking to do and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you representative of I
I don't have a question I just need to
repeat one thing if you could for me I
was trying to write it down so it was
after you had talked about uh the
portions that would be able to be
redacted if needed to be and then so it
was after that and before you had talked
about uh you wanting for to prevent
police from being able to turn it off if
they were having a conversation could
you just say what was between those two
because I wasn't able to write it
down I I saw that you were looking at
your computer so I thought you probably
had it written I'm sorry I spot it's
okay if you don't have yeah I don't
recall what was between those sorry
that's okay no problem okay does anybody
have any questions
representative representative
Balden thanks for taking my question
um can you think of any
situations um maybe like a noteworthy
case or something that would have
benefited from the defendant having
access to this evidence against them
like are there any
examples of when this would have
been useful yeah so I think the
defendant is entitled to these body
warant cameras as just under the
Constitution the issue is some
departments want to go get court orders
to provide it um that slows down the
process which is just bad in that it's
slowing down Court processes and
delaying trials but it's also bad for
the defendant um they have these things
hanging over their head um more often
than not they're already under
suspension for um imply consent so
having them resolve these cases as quick
as possible is just favor favorable to
them um and I'll also add that um after
I filed this bill I saw that the Senate
filed a version of this bill I think
there's issues with that bill uh I think
it might potentially cause more harm
than it's trying to fix so I think the
underlying thing that it's trying to do
is the same thing allowing defendants to
get access to it I think the concern I
have with it is saying that one
defendants can't
essentially copy it or get
representative sorry that's okay if we
could just please stick to what your
bill does and when that Bill gets here
we you can come testify that one and let
us hear that but let's stick with this
one thank you thank
you representative
Muse yeah one one quick question I'm
just curious if you have run into any of
the issues you've identified today as an
attorney in your
practice it tends to be uh just one or
two departments that kind of want to get
judicial um permission to um give it um
but the muting yes I get that all the
time one in the Departments who's
here almost every single well I don't
say every single case often when there
when there's a officer speaking with
another officer they are muting that
case it's common if there's two officers
involved and I asked and they said hey
we have to statute says so uh other
departments I guess don't really follow
that part of the statute because I do
see officer speaking with other officers
um so I would say that one is very
common um the releasing to the defendant
presently I think it's less of a problem
but it it can cause delays when it is a
problem so it should certainly be
fixed any further questions from the
committee thank you representative thank
you
Captain
Davey morning ladies and
gentlemen thank you for your
time I'm here to represent the New
Hampshire Department of Safety Division
of State Police in opposition to this
bill and the reasons therefore um amount
to the following arguments uh defendants
in criminal cases are are in fact
entitled to copies of their video
because it's a constitutional right that
they have the ability to confront the
evidence against them and mount a
reasonable
defense uh the State Police in our
stance on on body warn camera videos
it's pretty scrupulous we' like to have
a continuous record of the entire cont
from the point that it begins until the
point that it's over with um in the
midst of that uh recording there are
times where we will mute the reasons for
muting um very often do occur within the
context of conversations with other law
enforcement officers other Troopers and
those conversations are both tactical
where we discuss investigatory technique
or approach and uh in in other cases
they're tactical in terms of their of uh
their safety decisions about who will
move where when and why and therefore
there are aspects of those conversations
that really ought not be released to the
public because they reveal tactics to
help to keep us and the citizens that we
serve
safe
um to allow the the sharing of footage
by
defendants is a dangerous thing uh for a
person to mount a defense is obviously
baked right into their constitutional
rights and ought to be scrupulously
therefore uh defended and maintained by
law enforcement but to share a video
without there being automatically within
the court process a protective order on
said video so that its use is strictly
for the mounting of said defense is to
uh create what are secondary effects
whereby defendants will release video
that violates other people's privacy um
whether that's third parties victims and
Witnesses
and um to to put things in the media
before uh they're held they're held to
scrutiny in a court of law is really to
risk Fair trial for the very person
charged uh in cases where they are
charged the um with regard to
exculpatory evidence uh what is material
and relevant and is on video is saved
our policy saves our video for a hundred
years if we classify it as a demeanor or
felony arrest automatically and that's
the way that the system
works uh my grandkids May someday see
video of of a car stop I made yesterday
so
um with regard to uh officers shall only
use body warn cameras while in uniform
the repeal of 105d uh to Roman 4
um I would argue that a member of the
drug task force for example upon the
execution of a search warrant will be
wearing police Insignia and is therefore
in some form of uniform we do have our
detectives on occasion put these things
on uh tripods in rooms for the sake of
being careful to record their interviews
with
suspects
um the uh the other issue as you can see
with with my uniform Here Is We I had to
cut a hole well we had to cut holes in
all of our uniforms which is a great way
for a body War camera manufacturer to
ensure that we stick with them we 87
years of this uniform and now there's a
hole in it so um to expect anyone in
plain clothes capacity to to do the same
with their clothing I would obviously
argue is a pretty Preposterous outcome
uh that may not be the intent of of that
repal but uh the fact of the matter is
that our people who are not in uniform
do at times use use these devices though
they're not technically mounted to their
bodies they also do have outer garments
um our outer garments our rain jackets
our cold weather jackets they have these
holes and grommets in them as well and
so if they wanted to wear it then they
could throw that on and they could still
use it um within the context allowable
by law so uh lastly the repeal of 105 D2
uh 7A Communications with with other
police Personnel obviously muting is the
issue we maintain a continuous record uh
visibly and don't shut down the
recording that's something that I when I
when I designed the training for all of
our Troopers made sure that they were
aware of it's far better to have a
continuous record um we're big fans of
these as well because they do in fact
reveal a great deal about what the
nature of the interaction was the
professionalism of of the law
enforcement officer uh the attitude and
response of the defendant and uh are
just as likely to uh inculpate as
exculpate and therefore they're very
useful uh both for for our uh our
responsiveness to the public our
accountability and the same for the
defendant uh notwithstanding that the
law as written is clearly written in
such a way that that wasn't necessarily
its intent um it's it is very useful to
watch a person pour him or herself out
of a
vehicle uh on the actual event as
opposed to seeing a person who is
collected and well dressed and
well-mannered uh in a courtroom they
paint very very different pictures and
they ought so that will conclude my
testimony I appreciate your time thank
you Captain a few questions for myself
and the
committee um with regard to the muting
aspect for the benefit of the committee
so to kind of paint a picture what that
might entail for example if you were
conducting a motor vehicle search and
the search was based on information from
a confidential
informant and one of the officers says
to the other officer where did X say it
would be exactly
again would that be problematic if that
video audio were released to the
defendant and allowed to be shared yes
sir can you explain um another potential
issue let us understand what that means
like the conversation part of it yes sir
uh in in many of these conversations not
only do we talk about tactics okay well
you know this guy right you you've
stopped him a handful of times yeah and
he doesn't like me a bit so I would much
rather if uh you take point on this and
I'll just be in the background I'll
support uh things of that nature that
would in my in the opinion of the State
uh State Police would make issues out of
non-issues which are just personality in
some cases um potentially inflame the
the uh process of audification or or uh
create problems that aren't that aren't
really necessarily there there are also
issues of um their their ties to their
associations with other persons their
criminal records uh a lot of
intelligence information yeah he pulled
out a 238 Smith Street and we all know
that's a flop house that's a that's a
crack house uh whatever that might be in
in the case of ongoing
investigations um we could compromise a
lot of information that way so it's
really for that reason that that we mute
those and from the other
aspect the defendant um you say you keep
the tapes for a 100 years but if it's
not on the audio it's not there so the
defendant doesn't even have an
opportunity to um have a judge look at
it or listen to it in camera to see if
it's relevant to his case would it not
be possible for for you to go back and
and mute retroactively if a if a tape
was produced yes sir it is possible so
in the original recording itself that
data file either has the audio or it
doesn't if we mute then it does not if
it does have the audio file for example
uh you see it on on Cops sometimes
you'll see people speaking to a police
officer and they'll ask them where
they're going or what their date of
birth is you see their lips move but you
don't hear anything it may actually have
been recorded in the original uh file
but was uh redacted so that someone's
birth date or address isn't divulged on
National Television thank you yes sir um
representative
Newman I believe uh in your testimony at
some point you mentioned that a
requirement for the body to be in full
uniform when using the body One camera
is that in the bill or is that in one of
the one of the things that have been
removed where where exactly is that yes
sir uh the controlling statute RSA 105
uh- D colon 2 in section uh four uh
Roman four reads officer shall only use
bwc's while in uniform it doesn't State
what level of uni or what constitutes a
uniform it just says they they should
only use them while in uniform and uh a
clear provision there is for undercover
officers it would be pretty Preposterous
for someone to be drying buying drugs
with a the body warn camera on uh in the
midst of an investigation so that's
where the that's where that statement
exists currently in RSA 105 D2 officers
shall uh only use bwc's while in uniform
and this proposed legislation repeals
that okay so so if it is not repealed
it's far sorry follow yeah go ahead so
if this law is taken out yes sir that
requirement to be in full uniform will
not be there is that the correct
understanding uh and sir I'll I'll just
bring you back to the language itself
officers shall only use bwc's while in
uniform so you've used the word full the
term full uniform a couple of times
that's not what the statute says it says
that we shall only use these while in
uniform when in uniform okay yes sir
thank you
okay uh representative sing thank you
very much and thank you sir for your
testimony um I'm curious and as the
parent of a 16-year-old driver probably
extra curious um when you when state
officers make a traffic stop uh what
point does the camera get turned on and
at what point does it get turned off
great questions our system is automated
such that if my light bar is on the
moment I open my door there's a sensor
that activates my body warn camera it
will tell me so it stays AC activated
until I do something to either mute it
or to shut it off uh in my practice of
car stops and the way that I trained
everyone in the State Police to do it it
should be a continuous record it
accounts for the entire uh the entire
contact even moments where we're back in
the car so it's very common for me to
come back to my cruiser and mute radio
traffic other people's dates of birth
Etc being spoken over the radio uh to
unmute make my second contact let them
know what the determination is as far as
enforcement action back to the cruiser
they pull away and then I'll shut down
both my body Warn and my cruiser camera
thank you yes
ma'am um representative Bolton
again thank you for taking my question
um I think it's probably a little
similar to what the chairman was asking
about but if you're
muting portions of a recording are you
not essentially redacting in real time
and could that not then be done ret
retroactively upon a request of a
recording and and I guess generally my
question
is if you're already in a position to
control for privacy
violations why then oppose the
legislation um it's a matter of scope of
work when I uh to answer your question
yes uh affirmatively and proactively
redact uh an aspect of a recording on
the side of the road I am preventing the
release of what I expect to be
information that I would have to go and
redact upon review of the video um we
were 80 Troopers down out of our
compliment of 350 or so until a month
ago or we're 70 down now uh and a few
more to leave the notion of spending yet
more time in the office or uh off the
road not being out serving the public
and revie viewing all of that video to
make sure that those things are not in
there when uh by alternatively by
practice we could be sure that those
things weren't in there we we take the
approach of of doing it
proactively so I would I would I would
argue that um to have to go through all
that in terms of that much more material
for redaction we we'd need to hire more
people to have them to have them help
with that and we only have three now
follow up I suppose my follow-up
question was only uh do you feel there
should be a fiscal note attached to
this in the case of of uh should it
should it Advance further yes
ma'am Captain if um if you if you have
any idea about how many Motor Vehicles
stops that are recorded occur uh per
year uh it's it's thousands uh even as a
as a captain I I make many uh as a
sergeant I made more than a thousand a
year year we have a number of Troopers
who do that so we're within the first uh
within the first six months we had
several terabytes worth of data and uh a
gig of data which is a thousands of a of
a terabyte is an hour worth of video at
720p which is our our level so it's tens
of thousands without question so even
let's say um let's say it was 30,000
stops a year and only 10% of those went
to court and it was required you'd still
be required to go through 3,000 videos
and listen to the entire thing to redact
things that may need to be redacted
would that be accurate yes sir good
thank you um any further questions from
the committee of the
captain seeing none thank you for your
testimony sir thank you ladies and
gentlemen attorneys uh Enders and
halberton
it's Bill
M good morning members of the committee
my name is Stephen Andress I'm an
assistant County attorney in the Marat
County Attorney's Office I've been a
prosecutor for over 20 years now and
with me is attorney Halverson who is the
marac County Attorney he's also been a
prosecutor for around 20 years um we
opposed this bill essentially when you
look at RSA 105 D2 which is the body
warn camera statute it's a fairly
comprehensive statute it was a
collaborative effort through a number of
stakeholders came together to write that
language when you look at that statute
it can essentially be broken down into
two broad sections the first section
involves the creation of bodyw warn
cameras by law enforcement in the field
and the second section deals with
handling of the bodyw warn camera
recordings once they're
created that second section about
handling um includes a Prohibition on
copying altering or Distributing the
video it talks about guidelines for
access to the video it talks about
guidelines for storage of the video and
it talks about requirements relative to
destruction and retention of the video
and again there were a number of factors
that the legislature considered when
writing those
guidelines um in addition to police
accountability there was a a major
concern about privacy and privacy in
those
videos the current statute RSA 105 D2 I
believe it's section 12 has a provision
which says these videos shall not be
copied and that creates some tension in
the criminal justice system because
obviously defense attorneys want to copy
of that video we've taken the position
that we can provide access to it in the
sense that you can come watch it we can
send you a link so you can watch it but
we don't necessarily want to give you a
copy of the video that's something that
we've litigated a number of times most
of those um cases have ended up in the
court ordering us to provide a copy of
the video to defense um the the court
has taken the pro position that within
the statute it says except as authorized
in this section and while it's not
explicitly authorized in 105 D2 implicit
within that statute is a belief that it
will be provided to the defense for
Discovery most of the cases that we've
had the judges have said however it
should be under an appropriate
protective order and we've certainly
litigated um the parameters of what that
protective order looks like I think that
this bill is a good first step in the
sense that it makes it clear that these
videos can be provided to the defense in
a case but it doesn't go far enough in
terms of a protective order one one of
the first things I noticed when reading
this language is it talks about a
defendant in a criminal case it
overlooks juvenile cases and it
overlooks Administrative Hearings I
think that if you were to craft language
that says a defendant in a criminal case
is entitled to a body warn camera then
certainly a juvenile and a juvenile
delinquency hearing is entitled to bodyw
warn cameras and certainly in an
administrative hearing like a li an
administrative license suspension
hearing the respondent should be able to
access their body warant camera as
well the bill talks about the defense
being able to uh obtain a copy of the
footage but it doesn't talk about how
the prosecution can obtain a copy I
think it should be made clear that the
police can make a copy for the defense
the police can make a copy for the
prosecution both parties to the criminal
case have equal
access what concerns me is it allows the
defense to copy share and display the
data
data I think there needs to be language
within the statute that um has some
protections on that data once it's
provided to the defense attorney and
again there's already language in 105d
to that creates protections um when the
police possess the data for example the
police can only access these videos for
law enforcement purposes there can't be
a situation where the police are you
know someone says oh I stopped this car
last night you wouldn't believe what
happened and and a bunch of officers
gather around a computer and and watch a
video sort of at the expense of the
defendant or laughing at the defendant
under the current statute that can't
happen these videos have to be securely
stored in compliance with the FBI's cgis
guidelines because there was a concern
about these videos essentially getting
out or being leaked or hacked from the
police
department and I I think it it's worth
talking about what is actually on a body
warn camera video and I can give you an
example we recently had a case for a
driving well intoxicated case small
Department car went off the road into a
uh a utility pole so one officer shows
up on scene there's an hour and a half
of video when that officer shows up on
scene there's nobody there except for
some volunteer firefighters so the first
part of this body warn camera video is
the officer talking to volunteer
firefighters looking at the
scene a motorist stops and says hey I
was driving by and this is what I saw I
saw two guys get into a pickup truck it
was a red truck it went in that
direction so they get that individual's
name date of burf his
address uh they run the license plate of
the vehicle to try and figure out who's
involved in this and it comes back that
the the the truck is registered to an
individual who's in their early 20s so
the police off officer and some of the
volunteer firefighters have a discussion
about well who lives in the area who has
kids about that age that maybe they were
going to visit you know maybe somebody
knows something eventually the driver a
passenger who is in the vehicle and
another neighbor show up back on scene
and the officer speaks to each of those
individuals separately again we get each
individual's name date of birth their
address sort of their involvement in
this case
and and you wonder when we talk about um
the state may seek a protective order
from the court to
prevent dissemination of body wearing
camera footage when it implicates an
individual's right to
privacy you think well that case I just
described are there rights to privacy in
there in my opinion there are I think
that those neighbors who come down and
talk to the police and say hey this is
what I saw I think they have a right to
privacy and perhaps a right to not have
that footage put on YouTube by the
defendant I think that you know maybe
the passenger in the car whose head is
gashed open and is bleeding down his
face has a right to not have the
defendant have that video and be able to
put that on YouTube or or disseminate
it another recent case we had which sort
of brings this point home is we had a
case where the New Hampshire State
Police Stopped a car on 90 3 there were
three individuals in the car and each of
those three individuals ended up being
arrested the one of the individuals was
arrested on an outstanding warrant that
individual gave a false name eventually
the police were able to figure out who
she was arrested her on the
warrant when she's arrested on the
warrant she's crying she says I'm scared
I'm on drugs I'm afraid to go to jail um
she also talks about the fact that they
were actually going to buy drugs she
tells the trooper there's there's no
drugs in the vehicle but the other two
guys in the car have drugs on
them um the police end up searching one
of the the driver with consent he's
arrested for possession of a controlled
drug the other
individual um denies consent he's
actually seized brought to the New
Hampshire State Police Barracks where
they apply for a search warrant to
search his person based on the fact that
they know he has drugs on his
person eventually they get that warrant
they search him he's then arrested he's
transported to the jail and booked um
earlier the next
morning I was surprised because we we
litigated this about the body warn
camera there were 13 hours and 40
minutes of video for that
stop so almost 14 hours of video because
a number of Troopers showed up so he had
the same thing from a number of points
of view
um we had both body warn camera and
Cruiser camera so we have almost 14
hours of video and now I have to look at
those 14 hours of video and decide
whether or not that implicates an
individual's right to
privacy well it certainly strikes me
that I have to provide the video to each
of those defendants but do I have to
provide the video of the woman who's
crying about having a drug problem to
the rear seat passenger in that
car I mean I think she has a privacy
interest in that interestingly when the
police were conducting the search
warrant they ask the individual if he
has anything in his pants and he drops
his pants he also drops his underwear
that's all captured on the body warant
camera video well certainly he has a
right to privacy in his exposed
genitalia but do I have to then provide
that video to the other two codefendants
um I think when we we're looking at body
Waring cameras it's it's more than just
the police interacting with the
defendant it's the police interacting
with the public it's the police
interacting with Witnesses it's the
police interacting with people that are
having Mental Health crisis it's the
having medical crisis it's the police
interacting with intoxicated people and
those people have a right to privacy and
have a right not to have the defendant
put these videos on
YouTube so I think that clarifying that
the defendant has a right to possess
this footage is great I think it's a
good first step the problem is that we
need to go further and we need to put
privacy protections on this material to
say that the defense can't distribute it
they can't copy it it's my opinion that
at the close of the case the defense
should have to destroy any copies that
they have I don't see why they have the
ability to retain it and when I look at
other types of cases we do that for
example if you have a case with child
sexual abuse images or a violation of
privacy case where someone hides a
camera in a locker room and has a video
of a bunch of people changing we don't
give that out as Discovery to the
defendant we say if you want to see it
make an appointment come to the police
station come to the prosecutor's office
you can watch it as much as you want
but we're not going to give you a copy
of it and to the extent someone says
well I need a copy of it to prepare my
case we're going to go before the court
and say okay fine they can have a copy
of it but there needs to be restrictions
on that copy they can't further copy it
and they have to destroy it at the end
of the case because it would make no
sense for you to be able to hide a
camera in a locker room videotape
someone changing and then as part of
Discovery get a copy of that be able to
own it
forever um
as attorney Hines representative Hines
mentioned earlier there is a Senate bill
which um I think does address those
those concerns additionally when we talk
about this the language about officers
being in uniform with body warn camera
to me the reason that language is there
is because we want it to be perfectly
clear to members of the public and
Witnesses they are talking to a police
officer we don't want any confusion
with the fact I'm talking to the police
this is being recorded this is being um
memorialized so I think it is important
to to leave that in there and I support
Captain Davy's statement with reference
to Communications with other police
officers if you made it so that you
weren't allowed to have private
conversations what would happen is the
police would be making gestures to each
other or communicating in non-verbal
ways to you
know what do I do here do you think do
you think we arrest this guy certainly
um we know that those are conversations
between supervisors and and other
officers about what do you think I
should do let's do this let's do that
and they do have a right to privacy in
those conversations because if you took
away the right to privacy they just
wouldn't have those conversations it's
not that it would be recorded it's that
those conversations wouldn't occur and I
think it's important that those
conversations do occur with law
enforcement in the in the field I don't
know if you have anything to
add attorney Andress mentioned um uh a
Senate bill that was out there he also
mentioned the tension that exists
between having these materials and
getting them to defense Council I can
tell you that um uh in talking and And
discussing the the issue with the Senate
side of the house um I had either direct
personal conversation face Toof face
with members of the ACLU or by telephone
both with them uh with criminal defense
attorneys uh with senior leadership over
at the public defender office to craft
the bill that does virtually everything
that this bill before you does in the
Senate uh and I think that that
collaborative effort Builds on a
collaborative effort that established
the original
statute and um I don't want to get too
in too in depth with uh the other with
the Senate Bill unless there's questions
about it I'll certainly mention it but
um right um but uh uh other than
mentioning the collaborative effort in
the other side um we are not blind to
the fact that defense that defendants
need access to this to this material we
have no problem with that um but the
original bill was written so tightly
that it gave no flexibility it gives no
flexibility in the original bill for
creating an exhibit for
court which is surprising uh because you
can't copy it or edit it um we've been
having to do um to do all of our items
via court order uh and Via litigation uh
and it's tied up a a good amount of
court time uh on the court time side of
things uh the bill before you talks
about um establishing a court order for
privacy that may involve asking a judge
to do an in camera review view an in
office review of the body warn camera
material using the two examples attorney
Andress mentioned you'd have 14 hours
worth of video that a judge would have
to look at to determine whether or not a
privacy interest existed um and uh I
don't believe that's a good use of court
time uh I think it's can be addressed by
other
legislative
actions and other than that I'll defer
to uh attorney Enders as ain't follow up
to me and I'll gladly answer any
question
questions um thank you right off the cop
of my head I I have concern do you think
that allowing the video to be
disseminated um would have a chilling
effect on people coming forward to to
provide information to the police such
as Witnesses
and I don't think it would necessarily
have a chilling effect at first I think
eventually it may um because I think
once people realize that this is going
to end or potentially
can start ending up on YouTube can
potentially start ending up being edited
by a defendant and then put on YouTube
in the future um would certainly have a
chilling effect I know that for for me
personally having been involved in many
many body worn camera cases at this
point I know that for me personally I'd
be reluctant to talk to the police on a
body warn camera which is saying a lot
for a person who's been a prosecutor
over 20 years because because I don't
necessarily want that distributed to the
defense the public or being out there if
I could if I could answer that too um
one item is uh that hasn't been
mentioned is that some investigations
take officers into private homes and the
interior of your private home should be
sankers sacked you know there should be
no one going into your private home and
I can tell you right now that along the
lines of what attorney Andress says said
if if an officer came to my house
wanteded to interview me and I have a
body War camera I'm not bringing them
into the house because there's a I
believe right now that there's a
possibility of that camera material
being leaked out and the contents of my
house being being monetized by somebody
on a uh internet
video I know some of the uh most
entertaining videos um out there right
now are body camera videos and I my my
son who lik likes to look at the the
First Amendment videos
um never finds one from New Hampshire
and I I I like that um uh having said
that there there do seem to be some some
questions to your point that need
clarification further questions from the
committee Mr Newman representative
Newman thank you you mentioned in your
testimony that there was a sign
significant amount of work done in the
other body in this language that might
address some of the issues that
that you've
raised um do you think that language
similar to that if it were amended to
this bill might make the bill better to
get closer to what you think might be um
represent Newman we're we're not going
to discuss the Senate bill if you don't
mind please I'm I'm just talking about
language similar to it if it exists
Wherever Would that I'm probably going
to make a a study committee of this and
we'll we'll take a look at the Senate
Bill thank you so I'd rather I limited
the other side so um further questions
that don't involve the Senate
Bill seeing none thank you for your
testimony this morning gentlemen thank
you anyone else is there anyone else
here wishing to testify who hasn't
testified on the
bill seeing none I will close the public
hearing on hp1021
and open public hearing on HB
1022 my first
uh representative Hines are you going to
introduce your
bill are you going to represent
introduce your bill one22 I just opened
it
you ready thank you sorry uh thank you
Mr chair um um just again Dan Hines uh
way back from criminal defense lawyer
don't know it's particularly uh relevant
to this bill um but this bill what it
does is it amends part of our
prostitution um statute to change some
of those levels from a misdemeanor to a
violation level offense and I went
through the um the bill has various
paragraphs so some of it I think are a
lot more serious than others um so our
present law deals with felonies in
certain cases I'm not touching those um
in certain cases where it's a
misdemeanor I'm still keeping that
because I think it's more of an issue um
than just regular sex work so the things
I don't want to change is where
someone's a legal dependent and capable
of support uh they're being supported by
someone else that's remaining
misdemeanor or transporting another into
a state for sex work um I think those
are a lot more serious serous um in
regards to sex work um I think it's an
ISS interesting issue area of law where
it's legal to have sex with someone
unless you have they pay you or unless
you film it because then you're a porn
star um but I think there's various um
reasons of why we would want to reduce
the level of offense from a misdemeanor
to a violation level offense this bill
could help someone out who was a sex
worker and wants a career change um but
unfortunately they were convicted of
being a sex worker and now they have a
criminal record and they go to apply to
a job and the job says we don't want to
hire sex workers um so for just the
common run-ofthe-mill case this would
turn it into a violation level offense
um still against the law still has
penalties um and cour can I guess
address it in other different ways um
but I think it's important for to remove
the stigma of a criminal record on
people um just like we've done with
drugs over the years um so so when we
want to have people have the bill get
back into society um having criminal
record is not the best way to try um
accomplish
that I expect there's going to be
testimony that reducing it to a
violation will increase trafficking and
everything else I think that's
ridiculous um prostitution is not
illegal everywhere in this country
Nevada for instance it's legal um highly
regulated but legal they're not a Mecca
of sex traffickers um many other
countries in this world have legal
prostitution everyone's also not being
imported there um for trafficking cases
I I don't think there's any correlation
to it I think if anything it'll go down
um if seths workers um if it's not at
least the criminal offense um I think
they're less likely to need use the word
Handler or someone essentially
regulating how they're acting at the end
of the day this deals with consensual
conduct between to adults um if it's
coercive that's wrong um things can
address that my Stat or my proposed Bill
does not have does
not um lessen or do anything to any type
of trafficking it's still illegal um so
I suggest that this bill is just a way
for people who want a career change to
not have a criminal record thank
you thank you um representative Hines so
you mentioned um Las V or n
um which is an interesting case so what
Nevada did is they legalized
prostitution but they put significant
guard rails in place and controls and
regulations um providing for health for
the for the people involved um I I even
believe criminal record checks things of
that
nature what you're doing though is just
taking the the criminal offense part of
it but leaving everything as
is don't you think that if we were to
consider removing the criminal um
criminal aspect of it that we should
likewise put some safety barriers in
there instead of just cutting it kind of
loose to the wild
west I'd be happy with that um yeah um I
think at the end of the day the Nevada
NE sorry the Nevada model is a good
model um if there's any amendments or
study committee that wants to kind of
look into that I certainly support that
um I thought this was just a quicker way
to do something to address the issue but
yeah I like the Nevada model um if
there's anything that we could do to
make it work safer for sex workers I'm
certainly in favor of that fur the
questions yeah represent
Murray thank you chairman um I'm just
wondering if you had any contact with
people in the sex worker community over
this bill I have not um so know I didn't
seek co-sponsors for any of my bills
unfortunately uh so I was put them in um
I left them open to to co-sponsors uh
but no um in the past I know there's
been issues of I I think I did speak to
other legislators about how to address
this topic and we all came up with
different ideas on how what might be
best um so I think there's a problem and
I think this is one way to address it um
there's certainly other ways and um I'd
be happy with pretty much anything that
addresses this
issue
Muse how difficult is it for a sex
worker to get uh convictions annulled
currently I'd have to double check the
analment statute but assuming so our
analment statute U basically says for a
misdemeanor it can be an olded three
years after the what's called final
sentence so if for instance a lot of
times that's the day your sentence so if
you get a $100 fine that's your final
sentence the three years starts from
that day um the exception is let's say
it's a Class A misdemeanor which carries
up to a year in jail or some portion of
the fine is suspended for let's say onee
good behavior then that three years
doesn't start until that one year is up
um so I'd have to look at the statute to
specifically see if there's an exception
because there are a few crimes that
cannot be anned I don't know if this is
one of them I if it is then my reasoning
is wrong but otherwise the answer would
be three
years representative
Newman yeah I I just have a question
about the way that you're worded in the
bill and you've left in and what you've
taken out and it appears that you've
just moved things from a misdemeanor
some of them up to a violation you moved
some as from Felony up to misdemeanor
and then on the back until when you get
to P page uh the third page I guess it
is paragraph 8 you you remove a whole
lot of language from the bill I don't
see where that is duplicated in in the
bill and I'm just wondering why you took
all of that out and it seems to be a lot
of there seems to be a lot that's gone
and I don't know where it
went represent Newman you're talking
about um section eight section nine I'm
I'm talking about where after uh the
line begins out all the rest of it is
lined out yeah and it's unlike the first
part of the bill it went somewhere and I
don't know where it went and what effect
that has on the law thank you um look
that you are correct that was an
oversight it would made an amendment to
fix that I was not in my tent to remove
any of that uh my intent was only to
change penalties for part of it so yes I
agree this bill would need at a minimum
an amendment to put those back in um
looks like the numbering would have to
be changed uh I'm not sure it's my fault
for not looking back what the LSR is s
but that was saying thank
you thank you representative thank thank
you uh Miss Kell and Miss
chant
hi good morning Mr chair and members of
the committee my name is Pam kyg and I'm
the public policy specialist at the New
Hampshire Coalition against Domestic and
Sexual Violence um the Coalition is the
umbrella Organization for the state's 12
Community be crisis centers that serve
more than 14,000 survivors of Domestic
and Sexual Violence every year uh today
I'm happy to be joined by my colleague
Meg chant um together we are here to
provide testimony and opposition to HB
uh 1022 legislation that is
counterproductive to our state's efforts
to respond to human
trafficking good morning my name is Meg
chant I'm a program director at the New
Hampshire Coalition against Domestic and
Sexual Violence and in that role I serve
as the Director of the New Hampshire
human trafficking collaborative task
force um and I just wanted to add that
our crisis centers also are serving
human trafficking victims so the
Coalition is working with victims of
trafficking as well um the task force is
a multidisiplinary group led by a core
team comprised of representatives from
prosecution law enforcement victim
Services children's services and health
care we also as part of our task Force
have two funded Task Force officers one
full-time and one part-time they are
based at straford County Sheriff's
Office and the New Hampshire State
Police but detailed through the task
force to Homeland Security
investigations where they provide um
they investigate incidents of
trafficking around the state as well as
providing investigative support training
and technical assistance to any other
jurisdictions around the state in human
trafficking cases as requested to the to
the level requested by that agency um
the New Hampshire human trafficking
collaborative task force has worked hard
over the past decade to develop a robust
multidisciplinary response to
trafficking and the language in this
bill will reduce protections for
vulnerable individuals in our state and
create new Pathways to exploitation our
mission is heavily focused on supporting
victims um ensuring that anyone who's
been exploited is able to have a pathway
to stability and safety uh that's our
top priority um even above prosecution
and so our goal really is to Pro um as a
coalition and a task force is to protect
anyone who has been sexually exploited
or trafficked and this bill is counter
to those efforts I just wanted to
mention specifically um pertaining to
trafficking so as many of you I'm sure
know under New Hampshire RSA 6337
pertaining to trafficking a minor under
age 18 cannot consent to commercial
sexual activity so unlike with adult
victims of trafficking there's no need
to Pro to prove that the minor was
compelled to provide sexual Services
where there's a commercial exchange of
value and we're very concerned
specifically that the deletion in this
bill of language preventing there's
double negatives here preventing the use
of lack of knowledge of age as a defense
will weaken protections and safety for
minor victims and create an opportunity
for exploitation we're also very
concerned for adult and minor victims
alike that this bill will pave the way
for increased exploitation behind closed
doors and reduce the opportunities that
law enforcement and service providers
have to intervene identify victims of
trafficking and other forms of abuse in
order to provide life-saving referrals
to Services um my colleague from the
task force Lieutenant Tamara Hester of
New Hampshire State Police will speak
after us and she can speak a little bit
more about the approach that law
enforcement is able to take in these
situations and the tools that they have
at their
disposal um and I know uh representative
uh Newman asked about some of the
deleted parts of this the current
statute um so I just wanted to speak uh
to that uh really briefly um the
legislation um this bill would repeal a
law that was only recently passed in New
Hampshire so in 2021 this legislature
and I remember working very closely with
members of this committee passed
hb123 um legislated legislation that
granted immunity from prosecution for
prostitution for reporting sexual
assault um as we testified then we
believe that no rape victim who comes
forward to report an assault or to
receive Medical Care uh should be
arrested as a consequence um and making
that care contingent on their
involvement with law enforcement in the
criminal legal system isn't acceptable
um so we worked really hard to make sure
that there wouldn't be any barriers um
to someone seeking service regardless of
um their situation or if they're in
prostitution um so we find it really
alarming that that provision was removed
from statute because it's a a hugely
protective uh provision um and ensures
that victims are able to receive Medical
Care and other services that they're
entitled to in our state um so just to
wrap up um we just hope that you'll
consider voting no on this bill um and
we're always happy to provide
information on human trafficking or
sexual assault um to this committee um
and connect you with relevant experts
from our multidisciplinary team um thank
you so much and we're happy to take any
questions any
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony was
it Tamara Hester I believe Captain she
said
good morning representatives and members
of the committee my name is Tamara
Hester I am a lieutenant with the New
Hampshire State Police I am the current
commander of the special investigations
unit in which our unit we combat cyber
crime we work child exploitation
investigations and we currently have a
auxilary Trooper who is assigned to the
human human trafficking task force as
mentioned by the the Coalition they are
part of that multi multidisciplinary
team uh along with the full-time member
from the straford county sheriff's
office so they combat human trafficking
on the state and federal level as they
are Task Force
officers as mentioned by the um I'm here
representing the new campire State
Police dep Department of Safety we are
also opposed to this bill uh the
concerns for us are also the strikeouts
of much of the language in sections 7
through n of that current statute um as
mentioned by the Coalition recently
signed into effect uh that would be
completely removing the protections for
the victims of sexual assault so it
would be also be even more sexual
assaults are under reported as it is and
removing those protections would even
further the underreporting of uh sexual
assault for us additionally the language
um that is also removed about utilizing
age as the uh not knowing the age of the
individual removing that as a defense
could also allow further exploitation of
miners which occurs extremely frequently
online if an individual
um is able to use that as a defense in
the statute so that is part of the
reason that we are opposed to this bill
um it's very difficult from the
beginning to identify victims of
trafficking I know that um one of the
comments made by uh representative Hines
who is the sponsor of this bill was that
by lowering or decriminalizing as done
in some other states or as being
proposed currently would uh allow
individuals to potentially further gain
employment down the down the road um but
one of the as he mentions that is
consensual acts but also one of the
misdemeanor offenses that is going to be
reduced in the way that the stat statute
is currently written to be amended would
be that in Section 1 B induces or
otherwise purposely causes another to
violate sub paragraph a uh which being
that that is no longer a consensual act
for that person in the way that I I
understand that statute so that would be
a concern that the way that the statute
is uh proposed as well
now
um decriminalizing this has the
potential ability to continue to exploit
some of the vulnerable populations uh a
lot of the victims of human trafficking
that uh are dealt with on the law
enforcement side of things are people
who have either mental health issues or
substance abuse issues and we want to be
able to get them those services so in
decriminalizing it uh we therefore don't
necessarily have as much opportunity to
get them those services that they may
need um so with that being said uh the
department of safety is in opposition to
this this current bill
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you so anyone else
wishing to testify on this bill who has
not testified seeing none I'm going to
close the public hearing on HB
1022 and open the public hearing on
hb125 we
okay go
ahead thank you Mr chair um this bill is
related to the disorderly conduct
statute um so that statute is one of the
most broad statutes um some defense
lawyers like to call it a catchall when
police want to charge someone with
something hey this a statute to go to so
one part of this statute specifically
that I'm repealing or seeking to repeal
is what's otherwise referred to as the
fighting law Doctrine um so the statute
presently says it's a crime to direct at
another person in a public place obscene
derisive or offensive words which are
likely to provoke a violent reaction the
problem with that is I suggest that's
protected under the First Amendment
threats are not protected under First
Amendment we already have um a statute
dealing with criminal threatening if I'm
threatening someone that is a crime what
this statute does is saying my words
calling you something if you're likely
to react violently then that's against
the law think of the worst possible
thing someone can come up to your face
and tell
you if they say that to you you should
not then be able to respond and punch
them in the face um this um statute um
comes from a case years ago that went up
to Supreme Court chaplinsky um it's
unfortunate New Hampshire was the one
that led to that but like I said or
alluded to ear earlier it's What's
called the Fighting where's exception to
the First Amendment um thankfully the
court has in subsequent years um limited
the scope of that statute um so I think
now it's some limited to True threats so
as justest comples was a minimum wrongly
decided but even if not um has at least
been limited um under subsequent case
law the statute is pretty rare I don't
know that I've had anyone specifically
charged with this part um part of it um
being that it's possibly limited and
often I mean it's a First Amendment
issue um but one of the
things uh sorry let me look my
notes oh um the chaplinsky case I think
it's interesting the words that they use
that actually led to the conviction that
the Supreme Court upheld the person
called someone a town of I believe cev
Town official a damned fascist I suggest
that's pretty mild in today's um
political climate we hear presidential
candidates calling people that we hear
people calling presidential candidates
that um people should be allowed to
speak their mind um it's protected on
the First Amendment of the Federal
Constitution we also have a similar
under the state constitution I've
suggested to you that the worst possible
thing I say to you does not give you the
right to attack me people do not have
that right we already have laws
protecting threat threats against people
we have laws against assault um so I
suggest the statute even though it's
rarely enforced it's on the books I
think it's a bad thing and I think we
should repeal it and I'm happy to take
any
questions thank you representative do
you have the the names of the cases that
you said that have subsequently um
subsequently narrowed the definition of
fighting words if you do if you could
just email them to me so I don't
misspell them and have to I can't I can
it was mainly one case uh I believe it's
St Paul B B but
um yep so RV St Paul that was 1992 and
the other one I didn't mention Cohen V
California back in 71 and that's the
case referred to as the draft um
that was a case where someone was in
court his jacket said the draft
that was against the law and Supreme
Court said hey that's constitutionally
protected um I believe that more of an
obscene word statute not a fighting
words one but um it has essentially been
a little narrowed in that I would
suggest if I can say that I should be
able to say someone's a damn fascist
thank you if you could just email me the
case n i' appreciate it any other
questions for sponsor seeing none thank
you for your testimony
um uh major Chad
Lavoy good morning Mr chair and members
of the committee my name is Chad Lavoy
I'm a major with the state police and
I'm also representing the the department
of safety today and opposition of this
bill um we're not trying to take away
first you know Amendment speech or
anything like that from people I think
that repealing this part of disorderly
conduct um is basically a loss of ground
on the expectation of a civil society
that we have um I'm trying to think of
an example that I could give you and one
is basically a sporting event you know
you have a youth or a school event or a
kids sporting event we have parents
Spectators kids involved um AOW o ing
for this type of you know obscene
derisive or offensive words to be exch
exchanged back and forth in a school
setting in a sporting setting any public
building uh back and forth is just
opening us up for further damages
further crimes to be committed by people
in the public um regardless of their age
um I think giving humidities propensity
for escalation um law enforcement we
like to take interaction and and be
proactive and interact and and try to be
reactive and stop something before it
gets worse and I think allowing this to
become basically words exchanged back
and forth until basically an assault
occurs or anything like that is really
not what we're for we're here to stop
something before someone gets hurt or
more crimes are committed by those
involved and just opening this up to
allowing this type of um you know
slander and abusive words back and forth
uh is reasons why we are uh opposing
this bill it's
written thank
you thank you uh major Lavoy um I'm
trying to think of an example myself
what about um for example closing time
in a bar everyone's outside everyone's
inebriated people start back and forth
could that have potential to to lead to
um fighting as
people's um senses are a little bit
dulled from the alcohol they don't know
that maybe I shouldn't punch this person
after they called me whatever I mean is
that does that help diffuse the
situation or does it not help sure
there's going to be times where I think
where words are exchanged and you know
sometimes there is nothing that
escalates beyond the words that are
exchanged U but I think that we could
all agree that there are going to be
times where the words are going to
escalate someone's reaction uh to
hearing that type of verbal slander or
abuse towards them um that could
escalate to further crimes uh being
committed if you if you know um how many
times or how often is this charge
brought the fighting words portion of
it I would say it's not that often I
don't have an exact number but just to
guess I mean the majority of these
things within the disorderly conduct um
as you can see before it rises to a
misdem meter they're giving a warning
anyways by a police officer to stop
whatever they're doing that violates
that disorderly conduct statute okay
thank you other questions
um representative
n thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here um I just uh I agree with
what representative Hines uh said
earlier that that doesn't give you the
right to um impose physical violence on
on someone else um but so what I'm
wondering is you know is this kind of is
it that both people are charged is
someone uh who reacts in that way in a
physical way are they also charged with
assault if a physical assault occurs I
mean is this used as a defense for a
person you know what I mean in the way
that they're saying um oh this this
instigated uh my reaction and now I am
absolved from accountability for my own
reaction I don't know if it's used as an
excuse to to justify an assault or
anything like that but at the same time
I mean we're looking at something we
don't want it to go above and beyond a
verbal altercation if we can stop a
verbal you know abuse back and forth
between adults or children and adults or
whatever that's that's our goal okay
thank you um major if you if you may the
the common understanding that most
people have um with regard to words is
you know you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater um it's that's not used
as a defense or anything like that it's
simply because it can cause injuries by
people fleeing would you agree that the
fighting words is kind of similar and
that you it's not whether the person
hits you they get to use it as a defense
it's more used to stop someone from
escalating a situation that's correct
yes I would agree with that thank you
representative Muse
a lot of the concern that I have are is
use of this type of language in in
public meetings so if if we pass a law
like this um uh for example would would
chairman Roy still have the legal
ability to eject somebody from a
Committee hearing who uses this type of
language I think disorderly conduct
statute is Broad like representative hin
says but it does cover public hearings
and so forth within the statute if they
are being disruptive in a public hearing
or manner like that um but this just
takes away one more thing where someone
could be at a sporting event and just
saying these they might not be loud like
other terms are used within the statute
but they could be saying these types of
words to kids on a sporting field or
other parents within the stands and
that's really what we're trying not to
to get to at that point so bad dads
right correct okay
yes representative s thank you Mr chair
and and thank you major um I'm curious
how
this this Law relates to um people using
hate speech um using you know
specifically um like anti-semitic racist
homophobic or other similar types of of
terminology in a public
setting I can give you examples of many
you know large Gatherings when we went
through the civil unrest you know
through covid and everything after 2020
and um you know High you know areas of
you know frustration that we were
involved with as an agency I can speak
of and we are very cautious not to take
action when there is um you know
frustrations on both sides whether it's
politics whether it's a certain case
that it involves um you know we're not
trying to get involved in those aspects
it's more or less the words that are
exchanged that have the propensity to
lead to something
worse thank you um I guess I'm I'm
thinking there was a story in the paper
about a high school basketball game that
had to be ended um because students on
one team were uh using hate speech
against another that led to an
altercation right obviously that had to
be handled but so I'm not talking about
things that are necessarily directed at
police officers in various settings but
if for example I were to turn to one of
my colleagues and make a really hateful
comment about their identity in some
capacity such that it's likely to
provoke them to want to punch me as a
result is that covered under this is
what I'm trying to get at
yeah if they if they feel that it's
offensive I think what we're trying to
do is just stop that from escalating at
that
point yeah that's one problem with the
fighting words is it's not really
clearly defined what exactly they are so
it's situational um and it's up to the
law enforcement and then it ends up to
the court where they decide whether the
law enforcement made the right call or
not um okay further questions seeing
none thank you for your testimony thank
you Mr chair
uh chair calls Melissa
Davis to
me good morning my name is Melissa Davis
and I'm here on behalf of the New
Hampshire
Association of criminal defense lawyers
is that better thank you I
apologize uh I'm also a a professor at
UNH law I've been practicing criminal
defense for almost 20 years um and I am
the director of the criminal Practice
Clinic um I do want to say that you know
as I read this statute and it is a
statute I've dealt with many times
disorderly conduct I'm not here to
condone hate speech in any way um or
anything like that but I do think that
something that might be accomplished um
through this bill um that has not yet
been brought up and that could be
considered is um how it is applied to
juveniles so um as you all know all the
laws um and criminal uh statutes that
are in a force also applied to juveniles
um and it is I have really only seen
this offense brought in two situations
for the most part one isn't an
interaction with a police officer and
most of the time I'm in the position of
arguing that a police officer in that
situation is not being provoked to a
violent action uh because of their
training um but when it comes to kids in
school and things that are said I think
the statute is often used in order to um
maybe bring a kid who is upset
frustrated um challenging um dealing
with situations and using language that
people do not feel is appropriate for
kids um to then charge them and bring a
charge against them that then brings
them into um the New Hampshire uh family
court system into the juvenile system
which um I believe often times does more
harm um than anything else rather than
dealing with it within the school um and
the increased presence of school
resource officers um allows for um I
think uh investigation by law
enforcement into these types of offenses
when they would have previously just
been dealt with by you know School
actions suspensions teachers you know
getting involved parents getting
involved in whatever um but if they've
reached the point where they feel like
there needs to be some kind of um legal
investigation going on it's when this
charge often comes up it's really the
only place I've seen it um otherwise I
think you know it's not something that
we're dealing with I am sensitive to you
know sort of the Civil discourse that's
out there in the world right now um and
what's going on and um you know
definitely and I'm a proponent of people
being able to engage in conversation
which they disagree without resorting to
these kinds of things which is why I
think the statute
appropriately designates likely to
provoke violent reaction uh but I think
the intention here can and how it's
applied is often in the school setting
and I just wanted you to know
that thank you
um with regard to what you said earlier
where police charg people for saying
these things to them hasn't the court
already ruled that the police um for
example in disturbing the peace their
peace can't be disturbed does that not
also apply to um it doesn't I mean um
often times I would say you know
um it we end up still they end up still
bringing this type of charge it's not as
though they don't bring it because of
that issue we would argue that again the
statute provides the defense which I um
expressed about um not provoking violent
reactions on behalf of police officers
but it's still often brought um and
something that we're um defending
against and most of the time it's you
know oftentimes it's things that are
said in the back of Cruisers or you know
while arrest is being affected and it's
in combination with other charges that
um are going to get the job done uh More
Than This disorderly conduct charge
will thank you any questions for the um
represent uh the attorney from UNH
representative
Newman do I understand you correctly
that that maybe um a waiver for
minors incorporated into the law in some
manner would be helpful I think so I
mean I think um you I don't know how to
necessarily affect that um but that you
know within a school setting um that
perhaps uh there' be limitations on it
to some extent
um
yes thank you represent Reed thank you
Mr chairman so if a student is um you
know using words to the point of being
arrested um and having to go before a
judge don't you think that maybe um some
court appointed family counseling would
be um a better um help for this student
than letting the principal deal with it
um I just seems like maybe a a court
intervention is not such a bad thing I
respectfully I I think you're assuming
the outcome and that's oftentimes not
the result of what would happen based on
an arrest and on that kind of charge um
and I would argue that you know the the
resources that are available to help
parents um enroll their kids in
counseling if you know they are
struggling in some way or out there and
shouldn't necessarily rely on um the
delinquency system that we
have followup yes please so generally if
a student is a what what is the out what
is the you know what is the process
thank you they're given a petition um
then they're required to go to court uh
they're then given a lawyer um the case
is then either negotiated or it goes to
trial the negotiation you know can
result in a number of things um and does
it necessarily always include counseling
um especially if this is just a minor
offense like this violation actually is
um and so it's it's not always an
automatic outcome towards counseling I
think there there are other um systems
within the schools uh and that are more
able to direct a family to counseling
than the like I said the the delinquency
system I have a question so if you have
a student at a school say a high school
um you have some pretty big students
there and they're out of control they
won't listen um they're yelling
screaming
swearing does this not take a tool away
from the um the school and law
enforcement to extricate them from that
situation before it gets worse and leads
to assault and other violent felonies so
I'm not saying that law enforcement
shouldn't respond and attempt to Dees
alate I would argue that um I think the
school and the counselors and the people
that work with the students more
regularly are more able to deescalate in
that situation um the whether it leads
to a charge though I think is the issue
okay all right thank you um represent
wheeler thank you Mr chairman thank you
Professor for being here um so just to
be clear are you in support or
opposition or neutral to the bill or
you'd like to see the bill come out as
uh uh with limitations for students or
or you think that um it would be better
just left
alone I I do favor limitation for
students um or young people especially
because um you know of their age and
oftentimes when they are sort of just
for lack of a better term mouthing off
and saying things and being provocative
with their language oftentimes that is a
way to try to deescalate to keep
themselves from using physical conduct
and things like that um and I understand
it's disruptive but I again School
behavior is better at it I worry about
um you know uh vacating it completely
only because I do think um while there
are free speech rights if it's going to
provoke someone just out among adults in
the regular Community then then um the
statute is effectively dealing with
that you
good represent
n thank you Mr chair um I'm curious and
you know a little bit concerned about um
the implications of the lesson that this
would be that this is teaching to
Children um that there is essentially an
excuse for physical violence that you
know in my opinion that should be
limited to you being under physical
threat my question is um how do you
think that this affects children um
overall and do you think that that is a
good lesson to be teaching
I don't know if I quite understand the
question I think that um the existence
of
a uh penalty that would result in a
child entering the court system um I
don't think actually teaches the lesson
um in the situation about how to speak
or behave or have conversation um or
Express anger and I think that's better
left to counselors teachers parents um
um community and things like that I
don't think at the end of the day a
student when they are upset and swearing
is thinking I'm going to end up in court
and I'm going to end up you know sort of
involved in the court system um in that
situation just real quick followup um
okay so um you would
rather um amend it in a way that um the
consequence of that for juveniles would
be um some type of
alternative um
resolution not the court yeah yeah okay
thank
you just for clarification the this this
charge has to occur in the presence of
an officer is that correct this isn't
one that can be arrested for after the
fact or is it in the case of school
students you can be arrested after the
fact okay and you know it may be a
teacher it may be a school resource
officer it may be another you know
student or whoever that makes the
allegation thank
you
any any further
questions uh I thought you needed a
warrant if the officer didn't actually
witness the
event you would but that doesn't mean
you couldn't still go forward with the
charge after a warrant has been signed
yes and that that's really what I was
getting at it wasn't some a past
misdemeanor that you could arrest for
right on the scene you would have to
investigate and apply for a
warrant yes thank
you see no further questions thank you
for your test
morning anyone else wishing to testify
in this bill was not testified seeing
none I will close the public hearing on
hb125 and we'll be taking a 15minute
break
y
okay thank you everyone um for the
purposes of the committee
um
hb10 21 relative to um body cameras I am
appointing a study I mean excuse me a
subcommittee um on the subcommittee will
be uh representative Stone
representative
Manion um Representative salig no excuse
me um representative Muse and let me
see represent
what representative
salig wait a minute that's too many
that's
three okay yeah sake and I want another
Democrat I just
did yeah sorry don't confuse me I'm
already confus
enough I need one
more um I don't want her on that one um
1021 you said Stone Manion Muse yeah
okay that's good Stone Manion new and
sag will be on HB
1021 on HB
1022 um
another subcommittee with
Representatives
Murray
representative um let me
see hold on
St
all right scratch the subcommittee on
um you can share whatever wisdom with us
when we do the executive session um and
finally ex
um hb125 the subcommittee will be um
representative RADS
representative
new representative
Balden and representative Reed just
because she
hid I didn't hi fast enough um on those
subcommittees um I'd like those done
within U no more than two weeks please
because we have 56 bills and they're
going to stack up quick and I do not
want to be here in
May all right with that I'm going to
open the public hearing on
HB
1061 and
invite representative to introduce this
bill and before you start if you would
on the ones I um I committed um
subcommittees for if you could work with
the subcommittees please thank
you thank you Mr chair uh so what this
bill does is it turns uninspected
vehicles from a primary stop into what's
called a secondary stop so a secondary
secondary offense means an officer needs
to observe some other traffic violation
in order to enforce in this case the
uninspected vehicle um and there's a
couple reasons I think this is a good
thing so one it can actually help
officer safety um so a lot of times
officers when they're pulled over on the
side of the road that's the most
dangerous spot for the officer so
presumably this will lead to less stops
um at the end of the day there are so
many traffic laws and if officer wants
to find a reason to pull someone over
they're going to all they have to to do
his weight someone's going to do 31 and
a 30 someone's going to touch a line
someone's going to do something uh but
hopefully by making a secondary offense
officers can go on to more important
safety issues um so when a car fails an
inspection is not always a safety issue
we have emissions we could have minor
issues um and the officer they don't
know what the issue is they don't know
why a car failed um but they're
enforcing the law so this law changing
it to a secondary offense um if passed
and ultimately a lot of these offenses
are unfortunately basically a crime on
being poor a lot of people who don't
have inspected Vehicles it's because
they tried to get an inspection and
there was an issue with the vehicle that
um might cost thousands of dollars in
repairs and they just don't have that
money so rather than having to pay for
some non-safety issue to get their
vehicle up and running they'll just risk
it drive hope they don't get pulled over
for it um so this will lessen that and
um by by just repeatedly giving people
violations um for this offense they then
are now out fine money and still have to
deal with their vehicle um and I know my
bill only deals with uninspected
vehicles um if the committee wanted to
amend and expand to unregistered
vehicles I think that would also be
great that really is a crime on poor
people um changing that to a secondary
offense um so ask would support this
bill I'm happy to take any questions
thank you
um
when a vehicle is rejected in New
Hampshire is there a rejection sticker
put on the
vehicle it might depend on when you go
in because I think if you go in ahead of
time they won't take your present
sticker because it's still valid um I
don't know the answer to after the fact
whether they can remove it and put on a
failure so I don't know I just I've had
Vehicles rejected I know there's a
letter that they hand you that says why
it was rejected and will'll say if it's
omissions or safety issue issues um but
from the officer standpoint of whether
they can tell I don't think there is but
I could be mistaken on that okay thank
you I I asked because I know in other
states they have rejection stickers and
some of them will be a different color
for example for safety only and that
would be a r sticker and that would
indicate this vehicle is not safe to be
on the road versus just a warning light
that could be for anything so I was
curious um all right thank you any
further questions for the representative
represent whe
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Hines
um I think it's 11 states that don't
require vehicle inspection at all 36
states that don't require annual
inspections
um why if we were addressing the issue
of
inspections um and if it were uh a
negative against poorer folks would
changing it to a secondary offense be
better than doing what those 11 to 36
states have done and getting rid of the
annual inspections no but I think the
votes were there which is why I didn't
put that bill in this is a middle ground
so I think this is better than nothing I
would prefer limiting and altogether
didn't see that happening so I was
trying to come up with some Middle
Ground to at least make it less
bad representative Balden then
representative Stone thanks for taking
my question I'm aware you're an attorney
um in your work with criminal defense um
are you saying that
you generally see people of a lower
class or income driving with uninspected
vehicles versus maybe clients you've had
who are more financially well off is
that well so I think generally I only
I'm not appointed counselor public
defender so people would have to have
money to hire me um but a lot of times
people people um who get sometimes the
officers use this as a pretext just stop
someone and especially if it's late at
night like hey let's see what else they
might be doing wrong but other times
probably more during the day officer
just wants to let someone know and give
some a lot of times they'll give them a
warning but a lot of times they won't
and they'll give them a ticket um a lot
of times it just depends on how close
someone was so a lot of officers will
use gu I'll say discretion and common
courtesy if someone's over a few days or
a couple weeks letting them know about
it but the longer that goes by the more
likely officer is to ticket someone and
this offense is just a violation level
offense um I don't think there's a
mandatory minimum penalty um so I
believe it's like a $100 fine so at the
end of the day if someone has just a
$100 fine they're not hiring a lawyer
they're probably not going to court to
fight it um and they're probably just
mailing in a ticket um so hope that
is to your knowledge would um like a
conviction or whatever the terminology
would be for for um driving un inspected
vehicle would that result in points on a
license yep so while it's not a major
offense um and I don't believe it's a
minor offense towards habital Fender it
is points um so that can lead to
ultimately someone losing their license
and if someone doesn't have money um
they're really not going to have money
if they can't drive to work which leads
to then people driving uh while under
suspension which leads to even further
problems um are you aware if it's points
for the operator or points for the
owner I can look into that I assumed the
operator but I don't know that off thank
you um
also would that not also be caused for
an increase in their insurance rates
yes thank you representative Stone thank
you thank you for taking my question are
you aware of any other secondary
enforcement on the motor vehicle code
currently being done in New
Hampshire I think of it um off hand own
things so this is super common in other
states particularly with seat belts um
so I don't
know offhand I offand I don't think so
um but I know it's very common in other
states quick followup followup can you
tell me what the current fine is for an
inspected motor vehicle I can double
check it I believe it's around $100 but
I have to double check that all right
thank
you
representative
Newman having NE never ban a police
officer I have no idea what the sentence
that's inserted in bold in this bill is
and what a secondary offense is and how
that affects me as the person who could
potentially be guilty of this
specifically as to when I would have to
get my vehicle inspected etc etc yep so
you would still have to get your vehicle
inspected um it only comes down to when
an officer can pull you over for it so
if your car is just parked on the road
an officer definitely should not be
giving you a ticket for that um but if
you're driving if it's a secondary fence
an officer cannot stop you just for that
so if the officer observes no other
traffic violation just sees that your
car is uninspected can't pull you over
if he pulls you over for speeding he
then can also give you the ticket for um
the secondary
offense just
follow so then if it's a secondary
offense you would be noticed that you're
guilty of a violation or how how do you
then know that there there's an
objection to your having an unexpired
ticket y so the only thing that this
really does is determines when an
officer can stop you um so if it's just
the inspection violation can't stop you
if it's some other offense then he can
give you that ticket so the court
process would still be the same thing he
would assume he gives you a ticket he
could give you a warning still U but if
he gave you a ticket you would still go
through the entire court process you
could either be guilty by mail or have
your day in
court how about if I could just also add
that um an inspected vehicle some
officers I believe can it's never
happened to me when I was pulled over
for it uh but can actually tow the
vehicle causing further Financial harm
to people I believe for safety
violations um representative
n thank you Mr chair um I thought that I
should just time in as somebody who has
been guilty of this offense and pulled
over for this offense um just
forgetfulness and you know missing the
date um I believe the first time uh that
was the most imposition was because I
remedied the situation but forgot to
notify um forgot to you know respond to
the specific ticket but I I believe it
was a fix it ticket and then uh and then
I the other one was just a warning so
I'm wondering you know what kind of
imposition this is if there's a process
for uh being able to remedy it as long
as you um satisfy you know notify the uh
police and respond to the ticket as well
as uh addressing the issue itself yep I
would support that I think that's an
alternative approach to it um my bill
does not do that um but I think yeah
remedy would be also a good solution to
this problem um the problem is still
going to be it would help cases like
yours or others where they forget but if
someone knows that their vehicle's not
inspected because they can afford it
giving them a warning really I mean my
give him 30 days to come up with the
money but other than that isn't really
helping that
person represent Manion thank you Mr
chair just to answer your question I
believe it depends who the ticket was
written out to if it's written to the
operator would be on the operator and if
it written on the owner it' be on the
owner thank you um while we're having a
side exchange here um do you know if
there's a rejection sticker put on
vehicles I don't believe so but maybe TS
out I have one you have a sticker
temporary sticker put on for has uh if
you have a pollution dash light come on
so they'll give you a 30 days to fix
that because sometimes it's expensive
and it's not a hazard to the vehicle
gotcha
um to the sponsor again
um
if if we had
stickers
that delineated between a other
violation and a safety violation would
you think that that would be acceptable
for law enforcement to be able to stop
those vehicles with the safety based on
that I think from a public policy
standpoint it's more important to stop
unsafe vehicles um from the standpoint
of a driver who can't afford it at the
end of the day I mean they want to get
it fixed they just can't afford it but I
I still think that is better than
nothing I I and this is somewhat
rhetorical but somewhat not um the the
reason we have the stickers and they're
so big is obviously so law enforcement
can see them if it were a secondary
offense there'd be no need of those
stickers it it could be something
entered on a
registration and I don't know what if
any money that would save the state but
um there's
potential something if I were a sponsor
might want to call do and find out how
much it cost um representative
Newman yes thank you could an unintended
consequence of your
Bill be that somebody literally can say
I'm going to drive real safe all the
time but I'm not getting my car
inspected and he or she could go for
maybe two or three years without getting
stopped I think that's a good thing to
me that's an I would like that
consequence if someone's so safe that
they're not committing any traffic
violations not harming anyone they're
the ideal driver to me so I'd like to
see
that yes my followup would be in they're
driving around on bald tires and they
don't
care would I agree
yes any further questions seeing none
thank you for oh excuse me
representative side U I'm requesting
permission to make a comment because
it's not we're a hearing but I think a
comment is in order and I'd like to
start and you stop me if you don't like
it if it's appropriate here's here's
here for everybody there's part of our
culture and I got to pick you up on this
representative is that you said
somewhere along the way well let's the
cop will want to kind of hassle this guy
or find do something else or check I'm
sorry um I have a question of the chair
or a point of order or something is it
not is it not inappropriate to debate um
when we're not in
exec um I'm going to I'm just allowing
him a little way to make his comment if
it's objectionable I just thought maybe
it be better for I've been generally
lenient with everybody I don't want to
turn into that guy so I just hoping we
could make a practice of of uh of
framing our debate as questions instead
of overly debating thank you I'm
perfectly happy to stop I'm advertising
this as a comment and uh I don't really
want to get into a debate all I'm saying
is part of our culture that we accepted
that statement uncritically look I've
been in a report room for many years and
heard many candid conversations with
police and I've never heard anybody any
police officer say any conduct of that
type that they're out to do to hassle
they'll run a plate to see if there's an
outstanding warrant but that's the most
extremely your point is taken I
understand talking about our our culture
with regard to culture um I as the chair
I don't choose to rebut statements by
witnesses that may or may not be um
objective with regard to their opinions
of law enforcement or not um I believe
law enforcement can defend themselves
and we're here to just hear the facts
and the concepts uh thank you for your
testimony today thank you another car
thank you you're
welcome uh Mr
hon staff sergeant
hson good morning Mr chairman and good
morning to members of the committee
thank you for taking the time to listen
to me I have some prepared remarks and
then I will be happy to take your
questions um much like a driver's a test
uh it's provided uh to ensure the
knowledgeable and safe driving habits um
prior to getting a license uh state
inspections ensure Vehicles Upon Our
roadway are safe and both of those
actions both driving test and uh state
inspection uh ensure or the goal is to
ensure um safe safety on our roadways um
the New Hampshire data for um years 22
and
23 we've stopped and cited more than
10,000
drivers uh in that time period for not
having the vehicle inspected and that
doesn't include the warnings that we
issue either and I would venture to
Guess that there's probably a large
number that were just
warnings um that represents at least
10,000 vehicles that potentially could
have been unsafe for the
road um the in 2018 a national highway
safety administration published a study
which I have copies and I'll leave for
you
um of critical reasons for motor vehicle
crashes and approximately 2% of those
crashes which was
44,000 the critical reason was a
component failure or degreg of the
vehicle and of those um Vehicles
identified as having
a mechanical component that caused the
crash 35% of them were components
particularly um wheels and tires and
other uh 22% of those were related to
brakes uh a tiered approach to to the
enforcement of state inspections
undermines the safety of the public by
Leading them to believe that motor
vehicle inspections are not an important
part of ensuring our safe roadways
States would participate in tiered
enforcement see an increase in secondary
law violations consequently this model
was most likely to result in a negative
effect on highway safety and increase
the the possibility of motor vehicle
accidents a secondary inspection law
would most likely result in fewer
inspected vehicles on our roadways the
risk associated with operating a motor
vehicle which has not been inspected is
unknown uh to the off operator unlike
texting and driving or drinking and
driving you know what you're doing is
wrong um not having your vehicle
inspected unless you're a mechanic um
you really have no idea if there's
anything wrong with the vehicle or
not
um somebody that's operating an un
uninspected vehicle um is a lot of times
unaware if there's a safety issue with
with their vehicle a couple of things
that I I I want to say about Beyond this
is that we can't
quantify how many crashes were avoided
because we stopped somebody identified
the vehicle was uninspected and then
they got the vehicle inspected and or
repaired
so we don't
know as far as the question about a
sticker on a vehicle if your vehicle
goes in for inspection and it passes the
safety inspection but it does not pass
the emissions we put a 60-day sticker on
that vehicle so we can identify that it
has an emissions problem but not a
safety problem there is a process um
through the DMV that if you pass safety
and there is an issue with the emission
system that either is extremely costly
or it cannot be fixed there's a waiver
process with the DMV to remedy that as
well so we currently have no
secondary stop statutes here and New
Hampshire we there are none of those so
one of the other questions that was
raised or that I have is that without
having the bill right in front of
me this is New Hampshire registered
Vehicles
however I'm on the commercial Motor
Vehicle Enforcement side of things and
there is a federal mandate for anything
that's operated as a commercial motor
vehicle so so there's another component
to this that's not addressed in the
bill um this is a safety issue this is
not anything other than that
and
we're we're concerned with safety and in
the example of somebody that hasn't had
their vehicle inspected for three years
because they didn't in commit any other
um vehicle violation um we see vehicles
that are one and two years old that have
mechanical defects that fail inspection
and not being able to stop
somebody to remind of of that is it just
it flies in the face of everything that
we're trying to do as far as Public
Safety
goes so that's all I have like I said
I'll I'll leave this information for the
committee uh and I I will be glad to
take any questions that anybody has for
me thank you um Sergeant can you tell us
what's involved in the safety inspection
aspect of it what do they check for that
someone might not so basically what we
call critical vehicle components brakes
tires steering
exhaust um those are the big ones
obviously anything that would control
the
vehicle um yes and we do check the
emission system that's that's a Federal
Regulation that obviously we have to
follow as well but it's truly safety
again those components that um you know
we're not going to check the radio
that's not something that we do however
heater defroster all the lighting the
horn all those things that relate to the
safety side of of operating the
vehicle I've I've noticed in the last
decade um the more and more Vehicles
become computerized the more and more
systems that aren't readily available to
for you to self diagnose so a lot of
folks get failed because of a warning
light and the warning light could have
absolutely nothing to do with the
vehicle safety or emissions it could
have to do with the your seat heater
doesn't work anymore correct how does
how does the inspection station
differentiate or do they just fail you
if you have a warning line no so um
those things that cause a failure light
like that are not considered so it's
truly both a safety and emissions um
inspection but those ancillary systems
are not something that the inspection
station looks at they would certainly
call it out in their um report to the
consumer that a it passed both safety
and um emissions however there are other
problems with your vehicle it's not
something that it would get failed
for it was my understanding that they
were failing people regularly just
because there was any kind of light on
the
dash
thank you I'm I'm not aware that that's
a a common
practice representative
sing thank you um may I ask two
questions yes thank you so um are you
aware of of officers either state or
Municipal who deliberately seek out car
inspections um for the purposes of
determining whether or not to stop
some I I'm not aware no okay just for
clarification there's no difference
between that and saying I'm looking for
Speeders I mean it's an obvious
violation
so just thank you and um also you
mentioned that this doesn't address
commercial vehicles so if there were an
amendment to this bill that made it
specific to non-commercial Vehicles
would it change your perspective about
it being primary or secondary not at all
no represent
Newman thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I'm I'm interested
in you said there were a lot of warnings
that are given and so that I would I'm
curious
about why does an officer give a warning
is it relative to how the operator
responds or is it just it's a newer
vehicle or well obviously there's
officer discretion that goes along with
anything we do
roadside with a few exceptions so
personally um if somebody is at day 11
rather than day 10 so obviously the law
allows 10 days into the following month
before we can actually write a ticket so
on day 11 yes there are probably some
officers that would write a ticket um
personally maybe not uh maybe a warning
suffices um however you're right there
are some instances where driver attitude
does come into play there I I will
certainly say that um but for for the
most part um personally it's you know
did you forget uh or is there an actual
deficiency with a vehicle that needs to
be fixed um you know in this day and age
um yes people forget a lot of things
however um you know somebody that fails
to get a 2024 inspected probably is a
different um situation that somebody has
a 2014 or a 2013 vehicle that you know
hasn't been
inspected Sergeant is it unusual for
someone to say look there's I just can't
afford this thing is broken this
particular component it's going to cost
me $5,000 it's worth more than the
car we we I'm sure there are certainly
instances that that that does
happen followup yeah just a followup so
now I get a warning what what what
happens then as a result of getting a
warning do I
have to get stopped
again um no typically um at least in my
experience uh if I've issued a warning
uh somebody they'll go get their vehicle
inspected there's there's no system
though is there a system in place where
um Trooper a gives a warning Trooper B
pulls the same person over a week later
can he see that that person was
previously given a warning yes we we our
system allows that does that help
represent good U representative
Balden thank you for taking my question
I was just hoping to get clarification
on your answer to an earlier question um
if a vehicle has a check engine light on
um it's I assume it's my understanding
is it's failed um and I think the
question that the chairman was trying to
ask is if there's a check engine light
on um related to an issue that's not a a
safety concern how would the inspecting
um um shop identify that would it come
at some cost to the driver or the owner
of the vehicle to to make um make it
possible for the shop to identify the
cause of the check engine light and is
it possible that there are people failed
for check engine lights who don't have a
safety
issue so uh to answer your question most
every shop or I believe every shop um
has the ability to determine
what the system is that causes that to
to show up
and there are
certain failures of components in
vehicles and I use the radio as an
example that although it may be a
convenience issue is not a safety issue
or an emissions issue so it should not
cause that vehicle to be
failed um yes manufacturers are very
good about telling you when something is
wrong but if it's not any of those
critical components or it's not part of
the emission system that notification
should not preclude that vehicle from
passing
inspection it's my understanding that
and correct me if I'm wrong that each
time um so the the shop plugs the OBD
plugin it gets a code and then they have
to look up what that code means in
reference to that certain vehicle
correct and then they can tell what what
it is correct
thank you thank
you represent
n thank you Mr chair um I just wanted to
clarify really quickly um something that
you said in your initial comments did
you say that
25% of the uh stops that were made on
behalf of a um of a failed inspection
were breaks no that was I was uh
referring to the uh national highway
safety study that was done where they
looked at all the crashes looked at
those crashes that were caused or
the uh cause for the crash was listed as
component failure of those crashes 22% I
believe were noted as having being
related to breaks okay thank you I
appreciate the clarification and one
other thing that I I wanted to um bring
up is that um for New Hampshire a New
Hampshire alone in both 22 and 23 we had
at least one fatal crash that listed
equipment failure as the cause of the
crash
so everything else
aside we're our goal is Zero fatalities
in New Hampshire so having
one fatality based on equipment failure
and with the information I have I can't
tell whe you know whether that was
related to or what it was related to it
just is attributed to equipment failure
we don't know or I don't know sitting
here whether or not the vehicle was
currently inspected or not so we do have
crashes here in New Hampshire that not
only cause uh or equipment failure
causes crashes they also cause fatal
crashes as
well thank you um any representative
bden thanks for taking another question
just quick question
the single crash that you referenced um
do you know if it was a New Hampshire
driver if it was exclusively New
Hampshire registered Vehicles involved I
don't have that information with me I'm
sorry thank
you sorry one more question
the does the New Hampshire law
enforcement have the ability to stop a
vehicle with a inspired inspection
sticker or no inspection sticker without
estate
plates
on the non-commercial side
no so theoretically all of the drivers
in Massachusetts currently could drive
up here with inspired stickers and we
can't do anything about that only our
own Vehicles correct thank
you see no further questions thank you
for your
testimony chair calls Melissa
Davis
hello again I'm Melissa Davis I'm uh
speaking on behalf of the New Hampshire
Association of criminal defense lawyers
um I am currently a professor at UNH law
um the statements I'm making are not uh
those of unh or UNH laws um and I have
been a practicing criminal defense
attorney for almost 20 years and I
currently run the criminal Practice
Clinic at the school um anecdotally I
will say um I think many people have
experience with uh the state inspection
system I'm not somebody who's originally
from New Hampshire but I have been here
um 20 years I will say that I have been
uh seen things such as rust visible rust
a check engine light as well as the
manufacturer bumper on the Chevy S10
truck that I moved here with all be
subject to reasons for um failing
inspection just anecdotally um I think
that the question here is what what
happens here for people who are without
means and I want to focus on that part
of the intention in this bill because um
it's it is the cost of obtaining the
inspection but it's also the cost of
fixing whatever issues may come up some
of which may be very significant um um
and uh being able to fix them and then
the consequences of that so really it's
how should this be enforced um you know
my understanding is this bill is not
necessarily about whether we should have
inspection but how failing to inspect
should be enforced and the question is
should it be um the reason for an
initial stop of a motor vehicle by law
enforcement or is it something that can
be addressed um by law enforcement if
they are stopped for some other reason I
think the the issue here is one I will
say I do come across quite a number of
cases where the initial reason for the
Stop is um inspection sticker related
issues um what happens in that
situations is it's not as simple as you
know sort of come up Officer says you
know you have this inspection sticker
issue and that's the end of it the
questioning then goes on and it becomes
um a matter of sort of a longer period
of uh interaction between the driver and
the um law enforcement officer when the
next questions come where are you going
where have you been where are you headed
to what are you doing out right now and
this is not with any suspicion these are
questions that come all the time in
those situations um sometimes it does
lead to other um other types of offenses
and I would you know argue that my
clients I am courta appointed counsel
and I've been courta appointed counsel
my entire career um you know that it's
often my clients who are without means
um that are having the inspection issues
and then being stopped and then being
investigated um for potentially um other
crimes at that point will also say that
um the other issue is you know you get
this you stopped for this um offense um
you then may get a ticket for it uh that
is then money you don't have to pay um
that is then money that is owed to the
court if that doesn't get paid then your
license gets suspended um if you license
gets suspended you can't go to work
probably the reason you were driving on
the the car that had the failed
inspection sticker sticker was you were
trying to get to work um and you are
then if you are then driving to work um
either the registration or the license
has been suspended it's not due to any
um uh unsafe driving necessarily by the
operator but it's simply a matter again
of not having means in this state and I
can tell you these types of things
snowball um over and over and over again
I've seen clients who have um uh
convictions for operating after
suspension or operating with a suspended
registration um where they were not you
know committing any sort of vehicle
infraction that was a danger um it's
simply their status in that situation
because they have unfade P fines by the
court um they then enter habitual
offender status and so on and becomes um
this uh snowball of of money owed to the
court not able to pay it no license
can't get to work and it goes on and on
and on um I think again going to the
question of you know is that the
intention of enforcing this particular
statute um is that what we want to be
doing um and I would argue there are
other ways to to do so the officer
testified that you know they give
warnings on these things all the time
you know if if an if a vehicle is
stopped and the um officer notices that
there's an inspection issue they can
give a warning on that um that's an
appropriate way to deal with it there's
other ways that can be dealt with it in
terms of the registration system
although I would say I think that the
bill sponsor did offer to um add to the
list of this that it um expand to
unregistered vehicles I would actually
say unregistered vehicles
is not a safety necessarily a safety
concern is about being able to pay the
money um in this situation and and again
leading to the same types of
consequences in fact even stronger ones
because um being stopped for an
unregistered vehicle I believe is a
major motor vehicle offense and does
carry a much heftier fine than false
inspection sticker and so simply being
stopped for an unregistered vehicle I
would argue um you know creates these uh
uh issues for people without means even
um more
more any questions oh one I'm sorry one
last thing is um oftentimes the
unregistered vehicle thing as well it's
difficult to tell whose car is it
exactly I mean you could be driving
someone's else's car who where it's
unregistered in that
situation yeah thank you representative
Newman so do you feel that a second uh
making at a secondary offense would be a
resolution to both an inspection issue
and an unregistered vehicle issue
I think it lessens the
um it likely lessens the number of stops
and and the amount of enforcement on
this leading to um the amount of fines
that are accured um and the engagement
by law enforcement in monitoring
basically what is inspection issues uh
in this situation I think that
um yes it would do those things I think
there's other ways to to deal with um um
it yes I'm sorry if you need to repeat I
apologize if I didn't answer it
completely Professor is it is it not
also true and it's been a number of
years since my college days in criminal
justice but that Studies have shown that
something as simple as an inspection
sticker is often indicative of
situations in that person's life or
things they're involved in that could
lead to other things for example often
times people are stopped from inspection
sticker and police have discovered
someone who was being held hostage in
the car and a battered woman was in the
car who was wanted to not be with that
person uh parents who had children
weren't supposed to be I mean any number
of different crimes result from a motor
vehicle stop based on a a legal illegal
stop sure I I think that's the case
though and as I think the sponsor said
any one of us when we're driving at some
point some officer can find a way to
legally pull pull us over based on the
motor vehicle laws that we have and so
you know if there's some intention of
pulling a vehicle over um they can do so
and having this specific Statute in here
to affect I think the very far off and I
would say extremely rare situation um
where some other very significant
violent crime is going on at the time um
is too remote in terms of justifying the
real cost um on this statute to uh the
people who are without means in this
state the poor citizens of New
Hampshire thank you representative
Balden thanks for taking my question I
just want to make sure I understand your
testimony it sounds like you're saying
that the um by being by um inspection
being a primary reason to initiate a
stop that the result is
that um people of less means people of a
lower class or
um people with financial issues are more
likely to have protracted in
interactions with police um more likely
to be investigated whereas people of
means are less likely to essentially end
up in a situation where they're being
investigated for anything any smell any
weird movements um is that kind of what
getting at
yes I mean obviously if you can afford
inspection if you can afford to take
care of whatever issue your particular
inspection agent identifies um and
handle it and still engage in criminal
activities you're not going to be
stopped you know for that particular um
reason thank you see no further
questions thank you for your testimony
is there anyone else here wishing to
testify on this bill who hasn't
testified so far seeing none I'm going
to close close the public hearing on HB
1061 and I'm going to we've only got two
bills left so I think I'm going to see
where this goes I'm going to open the
public hearing on HB 1366 I know there's
someone here from the um fishery and
Wildlife I
think thank you Mr chair um so this bill
does two things and I'll say at the
outset I generally do not like creating
new crimes uh but part of what this bill
does is that um so presently um I only
learned this because I had a client
charge with it a while ago so you might
be more familiar with the motor vehicle
code so under the motor vehicle code we
have negligent driving uh which is
driving vehicle negligently and for that
there's no license loss um and minimum
$250 fine we also have reckless driving
and that is driving vehicle recklessly
um and that has mandatory license loss
of 60 days and also a $500 f plus
penalty assessment um what's interesting
about both of those K charges um if
you're driving a car motor vehicle is
they're both violation level offenses
now when we return to our boating statue
we have negligent operation of a boat
that's a misdemeanor I suggest it is
just as dangerous or if not more
dangerous to drive a car in those
Fashions than it is operate a boat so I
don't know why it was a misdemeanor but
I'm trying to get more in line with the
motor vehicle code um particularly for
negligent operations so of the two
negligent operation is lesser
culpability than Reckless operation so I
think at a minimum that should be a
violation level offense so um the first
part of what my bill does is brings it
from Mis miror down to violation but the
second thing is there's no Reckless
operation of boats under present statue
so this would create that um Bill
tracking our motor vehicle code um just
applying it to boats and I'm keeping
that a misdemeanor um even though in the
car side it's still a violation level
offense so I I be fine with both of them
being violation level offense but one of
the things that I think it makes sense
for it to be a misdemeanor is it's sort
of a compromise this original Bill did
have a misdemeanor offense level so if
someone is operating recklessly boat
fine that can stay misdemeanor but also
under our criminal code it's a felony to
operate or commit um Reckless conduct
using a dangerous or deadly weapon and
courts have said Vehicles can be a
deadly weapon so some departments in my
uh opinion uh I guess over prosecute
certain cases does tend to be the
extreme ones of reckless driving and
bringing as a felony so I was hopeful
that there's this misdemeanor approach
that people won't be charged with
felonies for voting um so it's um I'm
hoping this bill or that's what this
bill um does and hoping it'll go through
and I'm happy to take any
questions any
questions seeing none thank you well
stand by represent Murray has a
question thank you Mr chair um I'm just
reading where it says that a violation
of The Reckless operation of boats will
include a loss of a person's driver's
license for 60 days and the privilege of
operating a boat I'm wondering if the
reverse is true like if you get arrested
for recklessly driving would you lose
your boat
license or there is no I don't believe
so someone from State might be able to
correct me New Hampshire is a weird in
my opinion way to we don't really have
boting license we have like boter safety
cards um certificates other states we
can use I happen to have a California
one because it's super easy to get
California one um but I think generally
just ironic but generally I would say no
I could be wrong um however if you're
convicted of DWI in this state um
specifically you lose your voting
license for a year even if it's driving
more vehicle so since that's
specifically in the statute um I would
think this doesn't do that but I I could
be
wrong thank you see no further questions
thank you thank
you the chair calls Mr tin
donlevy good afternoon the chairman
honorable members of the criminal
justice committee my name is Tim Dunley
I am the retired captain of the Marine
Patrol unit for the Department of Safety
and I still work part-time uh handling
some legislative issues and and here I
am today thank you um we come today to
speak in support of this bill um as
you've heard previously We have dealt
with just this one charge of careless
and negligent operation for years and
we've had to juggle What charges were
appropriate uh because this was the only
statute we had on the books often times
we were Tak taking less serious non-m
misdemeanor type of uh offenses charging
them with careless and negligent at the
time of the the court hearing we would
reduce them to the violation before the
court obviously we've tied up court
because it's a misdemeanor criminal
offense criminal record people were
bringing it that far into the system
this now provides the officer uh and the
courts with the option to come in with a
more appropriate charge particularly
when we're dealing with the Lesser
offense
but it also gives us the tool to use
should the actions of a boat operator
rise to the level that should be a
misdem charge and is reckless with that
culpability in
mind uh the one issue that I will point
out with the language that's been
submitted before you today while we
agree
100% and this was just brought up um
when penalties cross over to motor
vehicle and back we have found um that
there is a manipulation of the system on
the boat suspension where defendants
will ensure that their suspension of 60
days in this case will take effect in
December January February because their
suspension becomes meaningless the lakes
of Frozen that is the case that happened
uh many years ago with the Boating well
intoxicated statutes and the driving
well intoxicated statutes there was an a
a significant effort made to make sure
that suspension never impacted them uh
by the by simply the timing of when the
conviction took place in the
courts so you folks in your wisdom
changed that to losing the Boating
privilege for one calendar year
regardless of when the conviction took
place they were losing it for one
boating season which for the typical
recreational boating season we're
talking Memorial Day to Labor Day about
95 days so well I'm not here to say that
the suspension should be 95 days I just
caution that the 60-day suspension
depending upon the timing of the
proceeding in the courts may be a mood
issue aside from that we we come
supporting the bill and I'm here to
answer any questions that you may
have thank you um if if the bill were
amended to to um
indicate the follow a year would you be
in support of them we would be we'd be
support if it's your wishes to keep it
at 60 days we would support that um
perhaps if it were 60 days between the
mo you know the days of May 1st to
September 1st what problems or issues
that poses the court to implement that
suspension perhaps six months down the
road taking effect I don't know the
impacts of that sir thank you further
questions representative sing thank you
so much and thank thank you for taking
my question um where do you see the
majority of um negligent and Reckless
operation boats um we find that often
times when there has been a boating
accident where personal injury uh is the
result the operator may not have been
impaired but may have been on a cell
phone or operating at a speed uh much uh
faster than they should have been too
close to Shore or around public docks uh
circumstances like that
sorry thank you um I guess I I should
have been more specific are you seeing
this more like Lakeside ocean I know we
don't have that much beachr 19 uh miles
but um are you seeing this more in our
Lakes regions versus our our ocean SE
sectors or we see it we see
it um on all our Inland Waters I I'll
stop short of calling it regularly but
often uh but on our Sea Coast for
example uh the one time one that comes
to mind for me was uh a gentleman who
had an autopilot an auton navigating
system on uh their vessel went down in
the birth and went to sleep and the boat
went into Ry Harbor and bounced off
three or four boats causing damage um so
there's a circumstance where we brought
careless and negligent operation forward
as the misdemeanor likely deserving um
so it happens on the saltwater as
well and for the committee's
clarification the difference between um
negligent and Reckless is mostly intent
is is that is that correct in other
words I intend to race you that's
reckless versus I took a nap and my boat
crashed is negligence right it's it's
it's that culpability is is the term
thank you certainly see no further
questions thank you for your teson thank
you all for your
time anyone
else um before I gavel this closed I
want to have a quick moment with
minority
if the sponsors of wishes we would be
inclined to EXA this with the OTP if you
go get an amendment that fixes that 60
days so it takes period between May and
September we will take a a one hour
break and give you the time to go get it
thank you if I could just ask so you
would want it may through September May
1st through September well just make it
uh Memorial dat of Labor Day of the
following year then or yeah the date of
well no from if it occurs during a
boting season any period that's still
left would roll over to the next year so
if you only have 30 days left in the
Boating season the first 30 days of the
next boating season you'd still be
suspended otherwise you it's just
throwaway and you don't get suspended at
all I believe so like if you got 10 10
days left in the
season um it have to carry over
otherwise it wouldn't have the effect
thank you
yes I just feel like getting something
done but unless you guys want to
leave yeah you know what um
Representative sitech makes a good point
um we'll we'll um we'll take this up
actually I can't I have to do it today
otherwise I have to schedule it and
notice it so just as quick as you can
we'll be I'll ask everyone to stay close
by um take 30 minutes everyone and then
start heading back here so that if he
gets back early enough we can take this
up and get out of here we are on uh
break
for what do we get left
minutes stand by everybody everyone
stand by everybody stand by I uh I
didn't realize we had one left to do
while we were doing that um so um
Brad can you come here for
second you were so close guys
sorry
um
I'm open in public hearing on hp1 1448
um the committee is uh GNA get that
men thank you Mr chair and uh thank
everyone for a long day um hopefully a
spill will be quick as well um so under
present law when someone's charged with
um generally a DWI um or specifically in
this statute DWI um if the court or if
during the course of that case their
blood is drawn what happens is the off
or photus draws the blood gives the
blood to the officer the officer submits
it to the crime lab the crime lab and
their infinite slowness months down the
road um analyzes that sample and
eventually gets that sample to the
defense layer now based on that sample
the defense lawyer may or may not want
to get that blood tested however the
statute say says presently that after
that sample is done tested by the lab
they only retain it for a period of 30
days needless to say cases are not
closed in 30 days I wish they were
coures are cases are incredibly slow um
so often
times I think it's just ridiculous that
the state is destroying evidence in the
middle of the case and that the
legislature has authorized them to do
that if this statute weren't there I
don't think any state lab would would
destroy evidence in the middle of the
case I would point out that it's a
felony to actually destroy evidence in
the case I've told the lab they are
committing a felony by doing this you'll
say they did not change their policy um
but I think it's just absolutely
ridiculous that blood in the middle of a
case is being destroyed by the crime lab
If This Were a rape case the lab
wouldn't be DNA testing stuff say ah we
test it and then we destroyed it after
30 days that's just absolutely
ridiculous they would be holding on to
that evidence this evidence could be
potentially exculpatory the reason it's
saved is so that the defense if they
want can get it independently tested um
our whole implied consent statute deals
with independent tests the defendant um
under the right before they're asked to
if they want to give a blood test or
refuse unless it's a felony case where
it's forced they are told you have a
right to get a sample of this tested at
your own expense that is meaningless if
the lab is actually destroying the
sample before the person gets around to
testing it now if someone hired a lawyer
early on in the process I know that the
lab has the blood and at some point is
going to send the results to me or the
defendant um generally speaking there's
not an issue with that um at some point
I get it but it's possible that that
notice doesn't arrive particularly when
it's like six months down the road and
no one followed up to get it but I think
what's more common is that someone who
doesn't get a lawyer right away CU they
don't need a lawyer right away the blood
samp out and depending on that sample if
it comes back essentially zero nothing
in the blood the police are going to or
the prosecutors just going to flat out
dismi that DWI um but if it comes back
above the legal limit then that's when a
charge might be brought so at that point
the person might get a lawyer M way
which is z Gil or they might wait a
while I've had cases where numerous
cases where someone retained me after
that 30 days is up uh now the lab they
don't exactly destroy it on the 31st day
they just go through Reg regularly
destroying samples so sometimes might be
closer 30 days I had cases where 90 days
later I requested it hoping they still
have it sometimes they do sometimes they
don't but eventually that CA that blood
is destroyed while a case is still open
and once it's destroyed I can't get it
independently tested so what this does
is this bill says stop destroying
evidence while a case is open and
specifically requires basically the
prosecutor or a court to tell them to
destroy it um now when I looked at the
fiscal note of this and how it came out
to $70,000 a year I'm guessing those are
those magical $70,000 hammers that the
US federal government buys this is not
that costly for the state to implement
so there's two parts of it guess they
would need more refrigerators um so the
samples are generally stored in a
refrigerator there would need some more
refrigerators um but the State Labs
already retaining the blood by the time
they get it tested we're generally
talking 3 to six months after the case
has been initiated now I'd say like 80%
of the cases are either going to be
resolved in that time frame or a few
months afterwards so the defendant wants
Cas is resolved as soon as possible um
often times in blood cases I'm just
waiting on those results to finalize the
case with the prosecutor so often cases
have to keep being pushed out until the
results come in but I want the results
as soon as possible um and as soon as it
comes in a lot of times cases get
resolved particularly if the blood is
Extreme one way or the other um high or
low for whatever substance they're
testing so I don't think it's going to
extend the lab actually holding samples
for a whole lot longer it might be
double instead of them having the sample
for 3 to six months maybe now they'll
have it six months to a year uh but
they're not going to indefinitely have
it cases are going to resolve and at
some point a prosecutor or Court's going
to submit a motion saying hey you can
destroy us the case is ended um so
that's the issue with the present statue
um this is my solution to fix it I'm
happy to take any
questions
yeah representative what um what if if
you know um what other states do with
regard to the blood sample um storage
time period I haven't looked at it just
when I first saw a statue I'm like I'm
just surprised it's there at all I I
think it's an issue and I think in
certain cases courts will dismiss things
so on appeal one of the best ways to get
a case reversed is um when exculpatory
evidence wasn't provided so
um so I don't know specifically about
DWI cases I'll say this is the DWI
exception to the Constitution so there's
a lot of them this is one of them um but
if we think of it for other cases why is
the state who's in possession of the
evidence in the case destroying it in
the middle of the case um I think it's
just absurd they're doing it for money I
don't think it's a whole lot of money at
the end of the day money is not a good
enough reason especially when it's not a
lot to deprive someone of their due
process right and and then blood is
going to be the strongest evidence in a
DWI case most times and it could be the
difference between being found guilty or
not what what other things have you you
changed I see that there's more here
than just requiring them to keep it what
else have you
added I don't believe anything it just
says when it requires them to keep it
and paragraph the new paragraph for just
says how they or when and how they go
about um not having to keep it anymore
so it deals with um saying they should
preserve it until has received notice
from the relevant
prosecutor um that they don't need to
keep it anymore so it's more of a I
guess procedural mechanism but basically
this says you have to keep it until an
appropriate time that you're notified
you can destroy
it represent
Reed
representative
Stone thank you than for taking my
question are you aware if the uh the
state lab seeks a uh judge's order to
destroy it or if they automatically
destroy it by policy or do they do both
they automatically destroy it by policy
um so their policy is 30 days like said
my experience they just go through when
they're full and just clear out older
stuff first um so it tends to be 90 days
or not and I expect that's that is
specific to DWI blood cases I don't know
in a drug case so I mean in a drug
possession case I believe the lab is
just saving that throughout the entire
course of the case like I think they
should so it's just these DWI cases that
have the exception that they're
destroying it um so my bill would allow
them to destroy it when the prosecutor
or Court gives them an order saying you
should do this um so me at the end of
the day yes the local department or
state police after the case is resolved
should be sending a letter to the lab
saying hey this case is resolved you can
get rid of the evidence and departments
do that all the time with evidence so
like I said the state lab doesn't just
do this um departments hold evidence for
a while and ultimately when they want to
destroy it um it's either by agreement
or they file a motion with the court for
destroying the evidence um and it hasn't
been a problem it's not going to be some
magical problem for the state to just
keep the sample for a little longer
thank you thank you representative
Newman
Su yes thank you for uh for taking this
question in looking through the um the
fiscal node and then the
methodology what jumped out at me was
the um the investment in freestanding
walk-in freezers and the space the
adequate space to accommodate them do
you have any creative thoughts
on where that space could be found so I
don't know if anyone from the lab I tend
to just by guessing I think they're
going to need double the amount of
freezers um so I don't know how many
they presently have or how big their
space is um but this says the cost of
each freezer is approximately
$10,000 I agree with that for them to
saying they need to store it for three
years I don't know where they're com
coming up with that number no
misdemeanor case is going three years
certainly the average isn't three years
maybe there's an outlier particular in a
felony case um so I mean the the crime
lab they have all sorts of evidence they
hold a lot of things that are
particularly much bigger they're able to
come up with storage I mean we're
talking about small blood samples yes
they have to be refrigerated so that
blood doesn't spoil U so there's some
electricity cost um so I agree there is
some but um I just think the uh numbers
are highly
inflated thank
you representative
Newman to go along with whether they can
store it or not
um who has access do the labs have
access to know could could you put
language in there that would say 30 days
as long as there is no continuing um
case involved the the problem is the lab
would then have to regularly follow up
with every Department to see if there
was a change I think that would be
highly expensive so I mean the much
cheaper way is the police department
knows the progress of their case when
the case is resolved all they have to do
is send a letter to lab saying you can
destroy this Blood
now represent B this proposal seems very
very pricey um would would it be
possible for the attorneys to to notify
the state labs and just say you could
just would that to me would seem quicker
and less expensive than all of this
thank you I do in every case I have the
problem is people don't hire attorneys a
lot of time or they wait to see what the
outcome is or they hire us when it's is
too late so I think even one lost thing
is just not right I mean it's costly to
obtain or store evidence but that's the
cost of our Criminal Justice System our
DWI when someone's found guilty it has a
mandatory fine I mean pres that's going
to the state um I think the money is
there um I don't think it's a huge cost
but even so people have a right to
exculpatory evidence as a reminder to
the committee um we have the luxury of
not worrying about the money we that's
for finance we just worry about the
policy so if we like the policy we let
them try to figure out how to pay for it
um representative U roads thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I think I just need
clarification to make sure I'm
understanding this
correctly are you saying that evidence
is thrown away destroyed before the case
is closed is that what I'm hearing like
over and over with all these yes
questions wow thank
you I'll just follow up when I request a
letter or when I send the letter to the
lab and they don't have anymore they
will say that it was destroyed usually
ask when it's destroy when it was
destroyed they'll tell me but yes they
destroy evidence during a
case
yes
representative
wheeler my apologies to my friend
representative Stone he has but um but
I'll take it though um representative
Hines thank you and thank you Mr
chairman so I guess to expand off of
Representative Road's question um what
is the reason that the courts give you
as an attorney as to why they're
destroying uh these blood
samples it's not the court giving me the
reason it's the dep part or the labor
crime land try not to cast any
dispersions
on they will tell us they will tell me
the statute says we destroy him after 30
days that's their reason um underlying
it's because of money but there's space
time but they're following the
law thank you represent Stone thank you
real quick just for clarification this
would also apply to felony level offense
dwi's Mr meor level offense DWIs for the
30-day
hold
I would say yes because it's in the DWI
statute to 265a is the whole DWI statute
so the felony DWI is when someone causes
a serious bodily injury so that's where
there's Force blood draws um so I
believe the I mean this references the
whole statute and I don't think there's
an exception so I doubt I'm wrong but I
would say yes it playes so for followup
that would be indicative of a case
lasting more than your typical 90 to 120
days for a felony level offense y um so
those cases are rare thank F so it's
when someone caused serious body injury
to another and then the blood was drawn
uh yes those cases do last longer um
ironically have had Superior Court cases
be quicker than district court cases um
they do last longer um so I would think
those cases again they make
up I would guess at most 10% of the
blood and that's really high I think
it's closer to 5% or less um but yeah
just on average I would guess double the
amount of time that they would have to
hold those thank you
um one last question I have is have you
had any in other words if they destroy
the blood and you make a motion to have
your client's blood tested and their
answer is we destroyed it are you
successfully able to get the case kicked
based on the fact that they've destroyed
the evidence or is the court basically
saying not too bad it's gone thankfully
I've never had to litigate it the last
time I had this happen um spefic
specifically what happened is apparently
the police department said we notified
the client client didn't acknowledge
notification or for whatever reason
didn't get notification and then the
Department's opinion was well they
should have known the blood was drawn
this was a weird case where someone was
hospitalized didn't actually know their
blood was drawn so they weren't even
looking out for this letter um but after
bringing uh the issue to the attention
of the prosecutor the case was favorably
resolved by plea so I haven't actually
had to litigate it um surprised it
hasn't been litigated yet
um I think it's because lawyers know as
soon as someone's blood drawn is I don't
wait for the result I tell the lab don't
destroy the blood um the other issue is
the lab does tell me so they'll hold if
they didn't actually test the blood yet
they will wait till the blood's test and
then they'll hold it until me I have to
pick it up within 30 days that's
reasonable like I don't want them
storing it forever when I know they have
it and I'm trying to get
it thank you uh representative
n thank you and thank you for taking my
question um so
we've you've talked about how the policy
of um you know the policy is 30 days um
and this would be changing it to ensure
that it was for the that would be the
statute um but further back as we were
talking about the fiscal note and things
like that and um uh how the state
police um estimated the cost and things
like that what they say at the end of
this is alternatively the department of
uh the department states that it could
uh return such blood samples to the
submitting agencies for storage so that
is um a a means by which it would not be
a concentrated expense in that way I
guess what my question is your that's
not explicitly stated as a statute and
so would that be policy that would be up
to um the uh State Police or Department
of Safety yeah so I guess I would leave
that up to whoever does those
administrative rules I think that is an
approach they could send it back um I
don't think the towns will like that
very much I think it's a lot easier to
have all this blood in one specific spot
uh but I I suppose that is a approach I
would suspect that might be an unfunded
mandate on on the towns um thank you
though um seeing nothing further thank
you very much for your testimony um and
the chair calls Melissa
Staples
good afternoon my name is Melissa
Staples I'm the director of the New
Hampshire State Police forensic forensic
laboratory so I'm happy to be here to
answer some questions you may have and
have been raised about this particular
legislative um
Bill the I'm happy that the sponsor
explained the 30-day policy as far as uh
what the purpose of that being that the
subject of the testing would have the
opportunity once they are apprised of
their results to pick up a sample of the
blood to have tested at the laboratory
of their choosing I think the 30-day
time frame uh probably came out of the
administrative license suspension
process because that states that upon
receipt of the report of their results
the subject has 30 days to requested
hearing uh an ALS hearing through that
process and I'm I'm I think this
probably was designed to mimic that it
sounds very simple uh just send an email
to the lab and they can destroy the when
the case is done uh the laboratory gets
around 2,000 blood samples a year and
these prosecutors are Prosecuting not
just blood samples but in toxil lier
cases they're very
busy they will not send these emails I
have a whole Warehouse of evidence of
drugs and guns and homicide evidence
that I wish I had an email from the
attorney saying it's okay to get rid of
these things now so the reality of this
bill is that we're looking at long-term
storage um because I also don't have
resources to find out who's Prosecuting
the case we don't have that information
the status of the case we also don't
have that information and so there's no
way for the laboratory to seek this out
uh to proactively try to get this this
approval from the attorneys to destroy
the Bloods so that's where the fiscal
impact comes in this truly is becoming a
long-term storage issue uh the
laboratory would require walk-in
freezers every so many years to continue
to store Bloods long term uh we do not
have space for these freezers uh in fact
A needs assessment performed in 2018
determined at that time the laboratory
was 2 and a half times undersized for
the people we have and what we're
providing the
services I think that uh we could um
without any fiscal impact uh store the
blood samples for six months uh and my
understanding from the sponsor's
testimony was that most cases resolved
within 3 to six months and extending the
time period that's on line four from 30
days to something more like six months
uh or even nine months whatever you feel
if
you're inclined to do so uh would allow
for that time period to be extended and
we have current facilities to store the
blood samples for that period of time
and so the fiscal impact of that would
be zero um so hopefully that might be
something the sponsor may want to
consider or the committee may want to
consider as an alternative that's
feasible and may accomplish the same
goal I'm happy to take any questions
that you have thank you
questions representative Stone thank you
thank you for taking my question so
something like 90 days would be
acceptable for not having an impact
fiscally I would go as long as six
months up to six months without any
Financial impact with no Financial
impact thank you
yes represent wheeler thank you Mr
chairman thank you Miss Staples
um you said that the attorneys are so
busy they won't even send you an email
for some some of the other uh evidence
that you have locked up would that be
something that you would like address by
the legislature as well a little oomph
to the County attorneys to get them to
well what we do and this was mentioned
earlier is evidence in in all this this
cases that we test do get returned to
the submitting agency and so that would
be an alternative um because the the
bill just says whoever's storing it
needs to store it until they receive
notice uh the submitting agencies are
certainly more familiar with who
precuing the case and what the status is
than we are so that is an alternative
and all the other evidence that we test
that's submitted by local agencies does
get returned to them for final
disposition the samples that we are
storing longterm uh representative
wheeler are drug cases submitted by
State Police uh Firearms submitted by
State Police and homicide evidence which
usually is investigated by the major
crime unit of State Police so those are
all specific to State Police cases that
we end up storing long term uh it's it's
very difficult especially for the
homicide evidence um because those need
to be destroyed through having a court
order which requires an attorney uh
usually had the Attorney General's
office assistance uh to to get that
process and it is just very difficult I
mean we're all busy we all have limited
resources and so we we try to pick away
at it um usually the drugs are a little
bit easier we can get trooper approval
and we get a court order to destroy
those um so it's a process I guess is in
short it's a process
um I'm looking at whether I am able to
add some resources to our evidence
control unit to try to pursue the
destruction of those things um because
we are running out of space um so you
need to keep on top of it we get rid of
one homicide case and another one comes
in you know so it's a it's a constant
challenge um that we're dealing with
thank you thank
you thank you represent shy thank you Mr
chair can we have a field
trip I'm sure we could arrange something
absolutely you just want to go to that
that giant
Warehouse that nobody looks like Raiders
at a lost AR I don't sometimes you don't
want to see what in
there um any further
questions but seeing none thank you for
your thank you very
much did you need to ask something oh
okay um so does that mean we're done Mr
anyone else wishing to testify this SP
was testified seeing none I hereby close
the I can right close the public hearing
is that that public hearing closed um we
will we're going to um we discussed it
and we're going to add that nine months
that sounds like a good bill and we're
going to see if we can pass that
today what is
it yeah can you tell representative
Hines I think he's in the hallway he's
making a call for the amendment can you
tell there's two two bills that we're
going to take up I have a question to
you and maybe for representative hin on
that previous amendment that you
approved does it apply to both the
driver's license and the Boating
operation the carryover to the next year
just the boting okay so he knows that
yeah okay thank yeah I specifically said
boting I I don't like that they're tied
together actually at
all hello um yeah let's take uh let's
take until 1:00 hopefully we'll have one
of those
back I
know
you
yeah
I
me
for
um Dan you need check one more time your
email see if you got
anything
okay everyone um I was hoping we get
those back but I I don't want to keep us
here longer they said it would be a
little bit and it's been over an hour so
um I'm G to say we're done for the day
so see you guys
tomorrow